It's been four years since I first learned about the disappearance of Neyam May, an 18-year-old who went missing from the small New South Wales town of Batlow back in 2002. I don't know if it's because Neyam and I finished high school in the same year or we shared a similar taste in music, but I felt instinctively drawn to her story. As I learned more about Neyam's story, the revelations that unfolded left me in shock. The result is Missing Neyem, the latest 12-part series from Casefile Presents. Researched and hosted by me, the series features exclusive interviews with key players who help us dive into the details of Neyem's case as we go back to Batlo to try and make sense of
距离我第一次得知内亚姆·梅（Neyam May）失踪的消息已经过去四年了。2002年，这位18岁的女孩在新南威尔士州巴特洛（Batlow）小镇失踪。我不知道是因为我和内亚姆同年高中毕业，还是我们有着相似的音乐品味，我本能地被她的故事所吸引。随着我对内亚姆故事了解的深入，随之而来的真相让我感到震惊。这就是《Casefile Presents》最新推出的12集系列节目《寻找内亚姆》（Missing Neyem）。该系列由我负责调研和主持，通过对关键人物的独家采访，带我们深入了解内亚姆案件的细节，并重返巴特洛，试图弄清楚
what really happened. The entire 12-part series is available now. Stay tuned to the end of today's episode to hear the trailer. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. At around 10am on Wednesday March 26, 1986, 12-year-old Michelle Welch and her two younger sisters left their home in Tacoma, Washington and headed north. Michelle and 11-year-old Angela were both on their bicycles, while 9-year-old Nicole was pulled along behind her older sister wearing roller skates and holding
到底发生了什么。完整的12集系列节目现已上线。请收听今天节目的结尾，届时将播放预告片。我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的电话号码建议以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您应用内或我们网站上本集节目的节目说明。1986年3月26日星期三上午10点左右，12岁的米歇尔·韦尔奇（Michelle Welch）和她的两个妹妹离开了位于华盛顿州塔科马（Tacoma）的家，向北出发。米歇尔和11岁的安吉拉（Angela）都骑着自行车，而9岁的妮可（Nicole）则穿着旱冰鞋，抓着
onto a skipping rope they'd tied to Michelle's bike. It was a bright sunny day in the middle of spring break and Michelle was in charge of her younger sisters while their mother was at work. Their destination was Puget Park, a pretty public space with a playground, grassy knolls, and more heavily wooded areas popular with walkers. The 1.2 acre park was less than two miles from the Welch sisters' home and only took them a little over 10 minutes to get to. The three girls played at the park for over an hour before they started to get hungry. They'd made sandwiches at home so they could have a picnic lunch, but had forgotten to
系在米歇尔自行车上的跳绳，被姐姐拉着走。那是一个春假期间阳光明媚的日子，母亲上班时，米歇尔负责照顾妹妹们。她们的目的地是普吉特公园（Puget Park），这是一个漂亮的公共空间，有游乐场、草丘，还有更多深受步行者喜爱的茂密树林。这个1.2英亩的公园距离韦尔奇姐妹家不到两英里，她们只花了10多分钟就到了。三个女孩在公园里玩了一个多小时后开始感到饿了。她们在家做好了三明治准备野餐，但却忘了
pack them. Michelle, who was a caring and protective big sister, said she'd cycle back home. Angela and Nicole could keep playing, and she would be back with their lunch very soon. Michelle hopped on her bike leaving Angela and Nicole at the park. The minutes ticked by. The two girls noticed that their sister was taking a long time to come back, longer than they would have expected. By around 12.30pm, more than an hour had passed since Michelle left. Angela and Nicole needed to go to the toilet and couldn't wait any longer, so they left the park to use a restroom at a nearby business. While there, they also used the phone to call their sister at home. No one picked up. Angela and Nicole headed back to the
带上它们。米歇尔是一个既有爱心又懂得保护妹妹的大姐姐，她说她会骑车回家拿。安吉拉和妮可可以继续玩，她很快就会带着午餐回来。米歇尔跳上自行车，把安吉拉和妮可留在了公园。时间一分一秒地过去。两个女孩注意到姐姐回来花的时间太长了，比她们预期的要久。到了下午12点30分左右，距离米歇尔离开已经过去了一个多小时。安吉拉和妮可需要上厕所，等不下去了，于是她们离开公园去附近的一家商店使用洗手间。在那里，她们还用电话给家里的姐姐打了电话。没人接听。安吉拉和妮可回到
park but still saw no sign of their sister. They played for a little while at a nearby cave before returning to the playground at around 2pm. There they noticed something. Michelle's bike was back and secured to a rack close by. On a picnic table was a lunch bag that had been ripped open. Inside was the food Michelle had gone home to get. There were some sandwiches, including one that was partially eaten, and a bag of Easter eggs Michelle had packed as a special treat. But there was no sign of Michelle. Something about the scene didn't look right. Angela and Nicole called out to their big sister using what the Welchers had dubbed their family call, a loud distinctive
公园，但仍不见姐姐的踪影。她们在附近的一个洞穴玩了一会儿，大约下午2点回到游乐场。在那里，她们注意到了一些情况。米歇尔的自行车回来了，锁在附近的架子上。野餐桌上放着一个被撕开的午餐袋。里面是米歇尔回家去取的食物。有一些三明治，其中一个吃了一半，还有一袋米歇尔作为特别款待打包的复活节彩蛋。但米歇尔不见踪影。现场有些地方看起来不对劲。安吉拉和妮可呼唤她们的大姐姐，用了韦尔奇家所谓的“家庭呼叫”，那是一种响亮而独特的
yelp designed to catch each other's attention. Michelle didn't return the call. At that moment, Angela and Nicole knew that something was wrong. They continued looking for their big sister. Their hopes momentarily soared when they heard someone calling their names, but it turned out to be their babysitter who'd arrived to help. They had phoned her earlier when they'd gone to the restroom and explained how Michelle wasn't with them. The babysitter helped look for Michelle and phoned the girl's mother, Barbara. Barbara was at work when she received the call.
尖叫声，旨在引起彼此的注意。米歇尔没有回应。那一刻，安吉拉和妮可知道出事了。她们继续寻找大姐姐。当听到有人叫她们的名字时，她们的希望瞬间高涨，但结果发现是赶来帮忙的保姆。她们之前去洗手间时给保姆打了电话，解释了米歇尔不在她们身边的情况。保姆帮忙寻找米歇尔，并给女孩们的母亲芭芭拉（Barbara）打了电话。芭芭拉接到电话时正在上班。
She was shocked to learn of Michelle's unexplained disappearance. Michelle had called Barbara just a few hours earlier when she'd returned home to fetch the girls' lunches. She was asking permission for the three of them to go to Puget Park and then stay there until Michelle's piano lesson later that day. Barbara had said no, as Michelle's lesson wasn't for another five hours, and that seemed too long for her daughters to remain at the park unsupervised. Michelle hadn't told her mother that they had already gone to the park, or that Angela and Nicole were still there waiting for her return. Barbara would later surmise that Michelle,
得知米歇尔莫名失踪，她感到震惊。几个小时前，米歇尔回家取午餐时曾给芭芭拉打过电话。她请求允许她们三个去普吉特公园，并一直待到当天晚些时候米歇尔的钢琴课。芭芭拉拒绝了，因为米歇尔的钢琴课还要五个小时才开始，她觉得女儿们在没有监管的情况下在公园待那么久太长了。米歇尔没有告诉母亲她们已经去过公园了，也没有说安吉拉和妮可还在那里等她回来。芭芭拉后来推测，米歇尔，
who was a responsible and thoughtful girl, must not have wanted her to worry. She'd likely assumed that going to the park would have been fine, hence why she'd taken her sisters there first without seeking permission. When Barbara returned home later that day, she found that the house was spotless. It seemed as though Michelle had cleaned it before returning to the park, perhaps as a way to soften any anger Barbara might have felt if she'd discovered what her daughters had been up to. Terrified, Barbara rushed to Puget Park and called the police. Initially, they told her she had to wait 24 hours before reporting her daughter missing, but Barbara was adamant that she needed their help immediately.
作为一个负责任且体贴的女孩，一定是不想让她担心。她可能认为去公园没问题，所以才在没征得许可的情况下先把妹妹们带到了那里。那天晚些时候芭芭拉回到家时，发现家里一尘不染。看起来米歇尔在回公园前打扫过卫生，也许是为了减轻芭芭拉在发现女儿们所作所为后可能产生的愤怒。惊恐万分的芭芭拉冲向普吉特公园并报了警。起初，警方告诉她必须等待24小时才能报告女儿失踪，但芭芭拉坚持认为她需要立即得到他们的帮助。
but Barbara was adamant that she needed their help immediately. By 3.10pm, police officers had descended on Puget Park along with family and friends of the Welchers. Over the following hours, police searched the park extensively, accompanied by eight canine officers. Dusk arrived and darkness fell, and still the search continued. At 11pm, Michelle's mother Barbara sat waiting in a nearby police car as one of the police dogs honed in on an isolated location about a quarter of a mile from the playground. A long wooded area dotted with walking trails abuttered the eastern side of Puget Park. This area was half a mile long and known as the Gulch. The dog had been focused on the Gulch when it headed off a trail and indicated at a spot about 60 yards into the woods where a makeshift fire pit had been crafted. Hidden amongst the grassy vegetation was the body of 12-year-old Michelle Walsh. She lay on her back with her arms outstretched
但芭芭拉坚持认为她需要立即得到他们的帮助。下午3点10分，警察和韦尔奇家的亲友赶到了普吉特公园。在接下来的几个小时里，警方在八名警犬的陪同下对公园进行了彻底搜查。黄昏降临，夜幕笼罩，搜查仍在继续。晚上11点，米歇尔的母亲芭芭拉坐在附近的一辆警车里等待，这时其中一只警犬在距离游乐场约四分之一英里的一处偏僻地点停了下来。普吉特公园东侧毗邻一片点缀着步道的茂密林区。这片区域长半英里，被称为“峡谷”（the Gulch）。警犬在峡谷附近徘徊，随后离开小径，在树林中约60码处的一处临时火坑旁停下。在草丛中隐藏着12岁米歇尔·韦尔奇的尸体。她仰面躺着，双臂伸向
either side, her hands muddy and tightly clenched. She wore a white shirt and a tan jumper which had been pulled up to expose her upper abdomen. There was blood on the clothing. Michelle was naked from the waist down, though she still wore her socks pulled up to her knees. Her left sneaker had been pulled off. Michelle's pink trousers and her underpants had been pulled down her body and were tangled inside out around one
两侧，双手沾满泥土，紧紧攥着。她穿着一件白色衬衫和一件棕褐色套头衫，衣服被拉起，露出了上腹部。衣服上有血迹。米歇尔腰部以下赤裸，但仍穿着拉到膝盖的袜子。她的一只左运动鞋被脱掉了。米歇尔的粉色裤子和内裤被拉下，缠绕在其中一只脚踝上，呈内外翻转状。
ankle. There was no sign of the pink framed eyeglasses she had been wearing earlier. The right side of Michelle's head had been fatally struck with a blunt object. Her throat was also slit and she had a defensive wound to one hand. also slit and she had a defensive wound to one hand. The suspects semen and pubic hair were recovered from the scene, confirming that Michelle had been sexually assaulted. As police lifted her body, they found a folding pocket knife with a sheath under her right leg. A small length of cord was discovered hanging from a nearby branch. Michelle's coat had also been draped from a bush. It was covered in blood, indicating the killer removed it after the murder.
她之前戴的粉色边框眼镜不见踪影。米歇尔头部的右侧被钝器致命击中。她的喉咙也被割开，一只手上有防御性伤口。她的喉咙也被割开，一只手上有防御性伤口。现场提取到了嫌疑人的精液和阴毛，证实米歇尔遭到了性侵。当警察抬起她的尸体时，在她的右腿下发现了一把带鞘的折叠小刀。附近的一根树枝上挂着一小段绳子。米歇尔的外套也被挂在灌木丛上。上面沾满了血迹，表明凶手是在谋杀后将其脱下的。
When Barbara Leonard was informed that Michelle's body had been found, she went into a state of shock and had to be taken to the hospital. Without the police saying anything else, she knew that her daughter had been murdered. As she recalled years later in an interview with the television program Dateline, quote, you know when you say found a body, it's not a person. It's terrible.'" Investigators suspected that Michelle had become worried after returning to Puget Park to find her sisters gone. She might have headed along the Gulch Trail in search of them and had been attacked by someone there. Another possibility was that her killer had seen her looking for the girls and opportunistically
当芭芭拉·伦纳德（Barbara Leonard）得知米歇尔的尸体被发现时，她陷入了休克状态，不得不被送往医院。无需警察多说，她就知道女儿被谋杀了。正如她多年后在接受电视节目《Dateline》采访时回忆的那样，引用：“你知道，当你听到‘发现了一具尸体’时，那已经不是一个人了。这太可怕了。”调查人员怀疑米歇尔在回到普吉特公园发现妹妹们不见后感到担忧。她可能沿着峡谷小径寻找她们，并在那里遭到了袭击。另一种可能性是，凶手看到她在找女孩，便趁机
told her that he knew where they were. He had then lured Michelle into the highly isolated fire pit location within the Gulch. Michelle had been found with a small cut to her cheek which could have been made with a knife. Her killer might have held the knife to Michelle's face as a threat while forcing her through the gulch. Michelle's family could think of no one who would want to harm her. Detectives took possession of some notebooks that had belonged to the 12-year-old and scoured Michelle's writings and drawings for clues. They found nothing of significance. Detectives appealed to the public for information. Although no one had witnessed Michelle's abduction, a 15-year-old skateboarder had almost certainly seen the moments right before it. He'd spotted
告诉她他知道她们在哪里。然后他把米歇尔引诱到了峡谷内极其偏僻的火坑位置。米歇尔被发现时脸颊上有一道小伤口，可能是用刀造成的。凶手可能在强迫她穿过峡谷时用刀抵住米歇尔的脸作为威胁。米歇尔的家人想不出有谁会想伤害她。侦探们拿到了属于这位12岁女孩的一些笔记本，并仔细搜寻了米歇尔的文字和图画以寻找线索。他们没有发现任何有价值的东西。侦探们呼吁公众提供信息。虽然没有人目击米歇尔被绑架，但一名15岁的滑板少年几乎肯定看到了绑架发生前的瞬间。他曾看到
Michelle at about 1.30pm walking around as though looking for someone. She then headed back to the picnic table where she'd placed her sister's lunches. The 15-year-old left to use the bathroom, and when he returned just a couple of minutes later, Michelle was gone. A number of sightings of suspicious men trickled in. One of Michelle's classmates who'd been at the park that day noticed a man watching the three Welch sisters. The man appeared to be in his mid-twenties, was short and wore dirty ripped clothing. A teacher who knew Michelle from school saw the 12-year-old talking to a young man with olive skin and dark hair. He was pointing down towards the gulch.
米歇尔在下午1点30分左右走来走去，好像在找人。然后她回到放着妹妹午餐的野餐桌旁。那名15岁的少年离开去上厕所，当他几分钟后回来时，米歇尔已经不见了。陆续收到了一些关于可疑男子的目击报告。米歇尔的一位当天也在公园的同学注意到一名男子在盯着韦尔奇三姐妹看。该男子看起来二十五岁左右，身材矮小，穿着肮脏破烂的衣服。一位认识米歇尔的老师看到这位12岁的女孩正在和一个皮肤黝黑、黑头发的年轻男子交谈。他正指着峡谷的方向。
A short while later, a boy heard what sounded like a girl screaming. He'd thought nothing of it, as children often screamed while playing at the park. A woman reported seeing a shifty looking man exiting the gulch that afternoon. The man moved quickly and appeared to be in a rush to leave the park. He was white, tall and lean and between 35 and 40 years old with short, dark blonde hair. A composite sketch of this individual was made and shared with the media. Some local teenagers said they knew of several men who lived in the Gulch and often sat and smoked beneath the nearby Proctor Street Bridge. On one occasion, one of the men had chased a teen while brandishing an
不久后，一个男孩听到了听起来像女孩尖叫的声音。他没当回事，因为孩子们在公园玩耍时经常尖叫。一名妇女报告说那天下午看到一个鬼鬼祟祟的男子从峡谷出来。该男子移动迅速，似乎急于离开公园。他是一名白人，身材高大瘦削，年龄在35到40岁之间，留着短的深金色头发。此人的合成素描被制作出来并分享给了媒体。一些当地青少年说他们知道有几个男人住在峡谷里，经常坐在附近的普罗克特街大桥（Proctor Street Bridge）下抽烟。有一次，其中一名男子挥舞着一把
air pistol. An employee of the Metropolitan Park District also came forward to report that she'd seen a strange man lurking around the Gulch Trail two weeks before Michelle's murder. The man had been walking along the trail, but each time he saw the employee, he ducked away into the heavy brush that grew next to the path. After reaching the end of the trail, he turned around and walked back again. Another composite sketch was made from this sighting, depicting a white man in his 30s or 40s with dark hair parted to the right and a bushy mustache. In the weeks that followed, investigators received numerous calls and reports from people who recognised the suspect's sketches. One tip-off came from a jogger
气手枪追赶一名青少年。大都会公园区的一名员工也站出来报告说，她在米歇尔遇害前两周看到一个奇怪的男人在峡谷小径附近徘徊。该男子沿着小径行走，但每次看到员工，他都会躲进小径旁茂密的灌木丛中。走到小径尽头后，他又转身走回来。根据这次目击事件制作了另一张合成素描，描绘了一名30多岁或40多岁的白人男子，留着深色头发，右分，留着浓密的胡子。在接下来的几周里，调查人员收到了许多人的电话和报告，他们认出了嫌疑人的素描。其中一个线索来自一名慢跑者，
who said he had seen the suspect hanging around another Tacoma park called Point Defiance Park, located about 3.5 miles northwest of Puget Park. Police interrogated every known sex offender who lived in the area, but all were eliminated from the investigation. The brutal killing had terrified Tacoma residents. Some members of the public began calling for lighting to be installed in Puget Park, along with a fence to separate the Gulch from the rest of the space. A community group called Friends of Tacoma Parks also launched a watch program at Puget Park to improve public safety. Many of Michelle's
他说他曾看到嫌疑人在另一个名为“点偏见公园”（Point Defiance Park）的塔科马公园附近徘徊，该公园位于普吉特公园西北约3.5英里处。警方审讯了居住在该地区的所有已知性犯罪者，但所有人都被排除了调查范围。这起残忍的杀戮让塔科马居民感到恐惧。一些公众开始呼吁在普吉特公园安装照明设施，并修建围栏将峡谷与公园的其他空间隔开。一个名为“塔科马公园之友”的社区团体也在普吉特公园发起了巡逻计划，以改善公共安全。米歇尔的许多
classmates were among the 200 mourners who attended her funeral and were driven there in a yellow school bus. Michelle was remembered as a girl who loved art, music, and writing. She was a quieter child who was almost always seen reading a book. Michelle's aunt told those assembled. She lived in her stories and drawings. Now she'll live on in the dreams of magic and delight. One of Michelle's friends performed a piano melody that the two had previously played together as a duet. In the weeks following Michelle's murder, the police investigation stalled as each tip-off led to another dead end. A $5,000 reward for information leading to the arrest
同学都在参加她葬礼的200名哀悼者之列，他们乘坐一辆黄色校车前往那里。米歇尔被人们铭记为一个热爱艺术、音乐和写作的女孩。她是一个安静的孩子，几乎总是被看到在读书。米歇尔的姑姑告诉聚集在那里的人们：“她生活在自己的故事和图画中。现在，她将活在魔法和快乐的梦境中。”米歇尔的一位朋友演奏了一段两人之前曾合奏过的钢琴曲。在米歇尔遇害后的几周里，警方调查陷入停滞，每一条线索都走进了死胡同。一笔5000美元的悬赏金，用于奖励提供线索以逮捕
of Michelle's killer went unclaimed. Weeks turned to months and the case began to go cold. Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. It's finally approaching the holiday season and I'm excited to head off to the US for all of the music festivals. But one thing that definitely shouldn't come along on any trip is body odour. Thankfully there's a deodorant option out there like Lume Whole Body Deodorant which is designed One thing that definitely shouldn't come along on any trip is body odour. Thankfully there's a deodorant option out there like Lume Whole Body Deodorant which is designed to keep you smelling fresh all day, from your underarms to your feet. It's clinically proven to control odour for up to 72 hours, making it perfect for long flights, hot days in the sun and even surviving a mosh pit.
米歇尔凶手的人，一直无人认领。几周变成了几个月，案件开始变冷。Casefile稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集节目的赞助商来支持我们。终于快到假期了，我很兴奋能去美国参加所有的音乐节。但有一件事绝对不应该出现在任何旅行中，那就是体味。值得庆幸的是，市面上有一种除臭剂选择，比如Lume全身除臭剂，它旨在……有一件事绝对不应该出现在任何旅行中，那就是体味。值得庆幸的是，市面上有一种除臭剂选择，比如Lume全身除臭剂，它旨在让您从腋下到脚趾全天保持清新。它经临床证明可控制异味长达72小时，非常适合长途飞行、炎热的阳光下，甚至在人群中挤来挤去。
They even make the perfect mini version for your travel bag. Casefile listeners are eligible for a special offer. New customers get 15% off all Lume products with our exclusive code and link. Use code CASEFILE at lumedeodorant.com. Casefile team member Paulina tested the Lumi whole body deodorant and loved the toasted coconut scent. It worked exceptionally well, keeping odor at bay, especially during intense activities like kickboxing and other heavy exercises. Unlike traditional deodorants that just cover up odor with fragrance, Lumi uses mandelic acid to prevent odor before it starts. Lumi's starter pack is perfect for new customers.
他们甚至为您的旅行包制作了完美的迷你版。Casefile的听众有资格享受特别优惠。新客户使用我们的独家代码和链接购买所有Lume产品可享受15%的折扣。在lumedeodorant.com使用代码CASEFILE。Casefile团队成员宝琳娜（Paulina）测试了Lume全身除臭剂，并爱上了烤椰子的香味。它效果非常好，能有效抑制异味，特别是在跆拳道和其他剧烈运动等高强度活动中。与仅用香水掩盖异味的传统除臭剂不同，Lume使用扁桃酸在异味产生前就将其预防。Lume的入门套装非常适合新客户。
It comes with a solid stick deodorant, cream tube deodorant, two free products of your choice like mini body wash and deodorant wipes, and free shipping. As a special offer for listeners, new customers get 15% off all Lumi products with our exclusive code and if you combine the 15% off with the already discounted starter pack, that equals over 40% off their starter pack. Use code CASEFILE for 15% off your first purchase at lumideodorant.com. That's code CASEFILE at lumedeorant.com. Please support our show and tell them we sent you.
它配有一支固体棒状除臭剂、一支乳霜管状除臭剂、两款您选择的免费产品（如迷你沐浴露和除臭湿巾），以及免费送货。作为给听众的特别优惠，新客户使用我们的独家代码购买所有Lume产品可享受15%的折扣，如果您将15%的折扣与已经打折的入门套装结合使用，那相当于入门套装总折扣超过40%。在lumedeodorant.com使用代码CASEFILE首次购买可享受15%的折扣。代码是CASEFILE，网址是lumedeodorant.com。请支持我们的节目，并告诉他们是我们推荐的。
You know by now how much I love my meal kits. The convenience of enjoying a tasty home cooked meal without spending hours in the kitchen is exactly what brought me to Home Chef. Their meals are so effortless, even someone like me who definitely won't be winning Top Chef anytime soon can whip up something delicious in no time. That's why Home Chef stands out from the rest. Home Chef brings fresh ingredients and easy chef designed recipes straight to your door. Whether you want classic meal kits with pre-portioned ingredients, 30-minute recipes or quick microwave meals, Home Chef makes it simple to enjoy tasty,
你们现在知道我有多喜欢我的餐包了。无需在厨房花费数小时就能享用美味家常菜的便利，正是吸引我选择Home Chef的原因。他们的餐点非常简单，即使像我这样绝对不可能很快赢得《顶级大厨》（Top Chef）的人，也能在短时间内做出美味佳肴。这就是Home Chef脱颖而出的原因。Home Chef将新鲜食材和简单的大厨设计食谱直接送到您家门口。无论您是想要预先配好食材的经典餐包、30分钟食谱还是快速微波炉餐点，Home Chef都能让您轻松享受美味、
stress-free meals for the whole family. Home Chef offers over 30 meal choices each week and caters to many dietary needs. They even have a tasty, kid-friendly family menu that's perfect for picky eaters, making dinnertime stress-free. Besides being convenient, Home Chef is also budget-friendly. Customers save an average of $86 a month on groceries. Olivia LaVoice, host of Casefile Presents series The Bakersfield 3, is loving Home Chef for its convenience and the high quality of ingredients supplied. She says it's also introduced her to new recipes she wouldn't have otherwise made. For a limited time, Home Chef is offering my listeners 18 free meals plus free
无压力的家庭餐点。Home Chef每周提供超过30种餐点选择，并满足多种饮食需求。他们甚至有美味、适合儿童的家庭菜单，非常适合挑食者，让晚餐变得无压力。除了方便之外，Home Chef还很经济实惠。客户每月在杂货上平均节省86美元。奥利维亚·拉沃伊斯（Olivia LaVoice），《Casefile Presents》系列节目《贝克斯菲尔德3》（The Bakersfield 3）的主持人，非常喜欢Home Chef的便利性和所提供食材的高品质。她说它还向她介绍了她原本不会制作的新食谱。在有限的时间内，Home Chef为我的听众提供18份免费餐点，外加终身免费
dessert for life and of course free shipping on your first box. Go to homechef.com slash case file. That's homechef.com slash case file for rating free meals and free dessert for life. You heard that right. homechef.com slash case file. Must be an active subscriber to receive free dessert. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. On Monday August 4 1986, a 13-year-old Tacoma resident named Jennifer Bastion decided to go for a ride on her brand new champagne-coloured 18-speed Schwinn bicycle. Jennifer, who was on her summer break from school, was a keen cyclist and was set to participate in an
甜点，当然还有首单免费送货。前往homechef.com斜杠casefile。即homechef.com/casefile，即可获得免费餐点和终身免费甜点。你没听错。homechef.com/casefile。必须是活跃订阅者才能获得免费甜点。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供高质量的内容。1986年8月4日星期一，一名13岁的塔科马居民詹妮弗·巴斯蒂安（Jennifer Bastion）决定骑着她那辆崭新的香槟色18速Schwinn自行车出去兜风。詹妮弗正处于暑假期间，是一位热衷于骑行的女孩，并准备参加即将到来的
upcoming long-distance ride on the San Juan Islands. As part of her training for this ride, she often cycled the three mile journey from her home to Point Defiance Park, a 760-acre space with a zoo, a beach, an off-leash dog park, and roughly 400 acres of old growth forest. The park sits at the north end of Tacoma on the point of the Kitsap Peninsula, and its five mile drive bike trail was ideal for cycling. Normally, Jennifer trained with a riding buddy, but on that particular day, her cycling partner was unavailable. Jennifer got permission to go for a solo ride instead and left a note for her parents, letting them know she'd be home by 6.30pm.
圣胡安群岛（San Juan Islands）的长途骑行活动。作为训练的一部分，她经常骑行三英里往返于家和点偏见公园（Point Defiance Park）之间。这是一个占地760英亩的空间，拥有动物园、海滩、无绳狗公园和大约400英亩的原始森林。该公园位于塔科马北端的基萨普半岛（Kitsap Peninsula）尖端，其五英里长的车行/自行车道非常适合骑行。通常，詹妮弗会和骑行伙伴一起训练，但那天她的骑行伙伴没空。詹妮弗获准独自骑行，并给父母留了一张字条，告诉他们她会在下午6点30分前回家。
It was 2.30pm when she departed. Four hours later, Jennifer's father Ralph noticed that she wasn't yet home as promised. He went out with some neighbours to search the surrounding streets, but there was no sign of his daughter. Ralph travelled the route that Jennifer was known to ride to Point Defiance Park and found no trace of her there either. He alerted his wife Patti, who raced home from work to help. At 8.30pm, the Bastions reported their 13-year-old daughter missing. Police immediately
她出发时是下午2点30分。四个小时后，詹妮弗的父亲拉尔夫（Ralph）注意到她没有像承诺的那样回家。他和邻居们出去搜寻周围的街道，但没有女儿的踪影。拉尔夫沿着詹妮弗常骑去点偏见公园的路线寻找，也没有发现她的踪迹。他通知了妻子帕蒂（Patti），帕蒂从工作中赶回家帮忙。晚上8点30分，巴斯蒂安夫妇报告他们13岁的女儿失踪了。警方立即
took the call seriously. It had only been a little over four months since 12-year-old Michelle Welch was murdered. Now, another young girl had vanished after heading to different Tacoma Park lands that was only three miles away from Puget Park. Officers immediately set out to look for Jennifer, and by 1am, two sniffer dogs and their handlers had also joined in. The dogs were given articles of Jennifer's clothing to smell and tracked her from her home to Point Defiance Park. They continued to pick up her scent on the park's 5-mile drive trail but didn't find Jennifer. Witness sightings allowed investigators to pinpoint Jennifer's last known locations and
认真对待了这通电话。距离12岁的米歇尔·韦尔奇被谋杀才过去四个多月。现在，另一个年轻女孩在前往距离普吉特公园仅三英里的另一个塔科马公园后失踪了。警察立即出发寻找詹妮弗，到凌晨1点，两只嗅探犬及其训练员也加入了搜寻。警犬闻了詹妮弗的衣物，从她家追踪到点偏见公园。它们继续在公园的5英里车行道上追踪她的气味，但没有找到詹妮弗。目击者的证词使调查人员能够确定詹妮弗最后已知的地点和
movements as well as confirm what she had been wearing – a blue or purple one-piece swimsuit, shorts, and a white bike helmet with red stripes. Between 2.30 and 3pm that day, a park employee had seen Jennifer bike riding near the Point Defiance Park entrance. At 4.10pm, three boys who knew Jennifer passed by her on 5 mile drive. They noticed she was being closely followed by another cyclist, a white man who wore mirrored sunglasses. He seemed to echo Jennifer's movements, speeding up and slowing down whenever she did so. Jennifer appeared unaware of the man's strange behaviour. Several more witnesses had spotted Jennifer over the next couple of hours, with the final sighting taking place at 6pm, a woman had seen her riding near
行踪，并确认了她当时穿着的衣服——一件蓝色或紫色的连体泳衣、短裤，以及一顶带有红色条纹的白色自行车头盔。那天下午2点30分到3点之间，一名公园员工看到詹妮弗在点偏见公园入口附近骑自行车。下午4点10分，三个认识詹妮弗的男孩在5英里车行道上经过她身边。他们注意到她被另一名骑自行车的人紧紧跟随，那是一个戴着镜面太阳镜的白人男子。他似乎在模仿詹妮弗的动作，每当她加速或减速时，他也跟着做。詹妮弗似乎没有意识到该男子的奇怪行为。在接下来的几个小时里，又有几名目击者看到了詹妮弗，最后一次目击发生在下午6点，一名妇女看到她在
what was known as the bowl area of the park. Over the next three days, police officers scoured the area in search of the missing 13-year-old. Roughly 230 searchers from numerous counties assisted. Meanwhile, the Bastion family and their friends stood at the park's entrance, handing out missing persons flyers to passers-by. Patty Bastion worked for a telecommunications company, which provided four cell phones to be used by the command center, facilitating easier communication during the search. But no trace of Jennifer, or the new bike she was so proud of, was found. Almost immediately, police, the public, and the media began drawing comparisons to the
公园所谓的“碗状区域”（bowl area）附近骑行。在接下来的三天里，警察在公园内搜寻失踪的13岁女孩。来自多个县的约230名搜救人员提供了协助。与此同时，巴斯蒂安一家和他们的朋友站在公园入口处，向路人分发失踪人员传单。帕蒂·巴斯蒂安在一家电信公司工作，该公司提供了四部手机供指挥中心使用，以便在搜寻过程中进行更便捷的沟通。但没有发现詹妮弗或她引以为傲的新自行车的任何踪迹。几乎立刻，警方、公众和媒体就开始将此案与
Michelle Welch case. Both girls had disappeared after riding their bikes to a Tacoma park. They were just one year apart in age and even looked similar, both with blonde hair and blue eyes, though Michelle had long hair while Jennifer wore hers short. A key difference was that Michelle was found in the park she had been visiting just hours after disappearing, while officers had scoured Point Defiance Park for days with no trace of Jennifer. Days turned to weeks and there was still no sign of the missing 13-year-old. Posters alerting people to Jennifer's disappearance were displayed all along the route from her home to Point Defiance Park, asking anyone who knew anything to report it.
米歇尔·韦尔奇案进行比较。两个女孩都是在骑自行车去塔科马公园后失踪的。她们年龄仅相差一岁，甚至长相也很相似，都有金发和蓝眼睛，尽管米歇尔留着长发，而詹妮弗留着短发。一个关键的区别是，米歇尔在失踪后仅几个小时就在她去过的公园里被发现，而警察在点偏见公园搜寻了几天却没有任何詹妮弗的踪迹。日子一天天过去，几周过去了，失踪的13岁女孩仍无音讯。提醒人们注意詹妮弗失踪的海报张贴在从她家到点偏见公园的沿途，请求任何知情者举报。
Psychics and members of the public called in to report possible tip-offs. None of these led anywhere. None of these led anywhere. Still, Jennifer's family held out hope. Shortly after Jennifer went missing, the Bastions were visited at home by Michelle Welch's mother, Barbara, and her sister. Barbara was all too aware of the pain the Bastions were enduring and wanted to share her sympathy as well as her hope that Jennifer would be returned to them unharmed. Patti Bastion was touched by Barbara's kind gesture and found her to be very nice. However, she struggled to understand why Barbara had visited because she believed Jennifer's case was very different to Michelle's. After Barbara left, Patty turned to a friend who was sitting beside her and said, I'm not sure why she came. Jennifer's not dead.
灵媒和公众成员打来电话报告可能的线索。这些都没有结果。这些都没有结果。尽管如此，詹妮弗的家人仍抱有希望。詹妮弗失踪后不久，米歇尔·韦尔奇的母亲芭芭拉和她的妹妹来到巴斯蒂安家探望。芭芭拉非常清楚巴斯蒂安一家正在承受的痛苦，她想表达她的同情，并希望詹妮弗能平安归来。帕蒂·巴斯蒂安被芭芭拉的善意举动所感动，觉得她人很好。然而，她很难理解芭芭拉为什么要来，因为她认为詹妮弗的案子和米歇尔的非常不同。芭芭拉离开后，帕蒂转向坐在她身边的朋友说：“我不确定她为什么来。詹妮弗没死。”
On Tuesday August 26, just over three weeks since Jennifer went missing, police received a tip-off from a man who'd been out jogging in Point Defiance Park with a running club. Their route had taken them along Five Mile Drive and the man had noticed a foul odour. Park police and members of the Tacoma Police Department were dispatched to the location along with a sniffer dog, but couldn't find the source of the Tacoma Police Department were dispatched to the location along with a sniffer dog, but couldn't find the source of the smell. Still, they continued to focus on the general location. Two days later, on Thursday August 28, a German Shepherd search dog honed in on a wooded area off Five Mile Drive. It was about 150 feet from the path and positioned between the road and the peninsula's cliffs.
8月26日星期二，距离詹妮弗失踪已经过去三个多星期了，警方收到了一名男子的线索，他当时正和一个跑步俱乐部在点偏见公园慢跑。他们的路线经过了五英里车行道，该男子注意到一股恶臭。公园警察和塔科马警察局的成员被派往该地点，并带了一只嗅探犬，但无法找到气味的来源。塔科马警察局的成员被派往该地点，并带了一只嗅探犬，但无法找到气味的来源。尽管如此，他们继续专注于该大致位置。两天后，即8月28日星期四，一只德国牧羊犬搜救犬在五英里车行道旁的一片林区停了下来。它距离小径约150英尺，位于道路和半岛悬崖之间。
The dog led searchers to a spot that was difficult to reach due to the dense vegetation. On closer inspection, the location was a kind of hollowed out cave in the ground hidden from view by the trees and brush. It looked as though it had been prepared ahead of time by someone who knew the park's woods and trails extremely well. Officers had to climb down into the cave-like space in order to see inside. There lay the body of a young girl. It was Jennifer Bastion. She was lying on her back with her legs apart and arms outstretched. Her swimsuit and shorts had been pulled down around her right ankle. She still wore her socks, shoes and bicycle gloves. Her state of undress and the way her body had been posed implied that she had been sexually assaulted, but her remains were too decomposed to confirm whether or not she had been raped. A ligature made from
警犬带领搜救人员来到一个因植被茂密而难以到达的地方。仔细检查后，该地点是一个地面上的洞穴状空间，被树木和灌木遮挡，从外面看不见。看起来它像是被一个非常熟悉公园树林和小径的人提前准备好的。警察必须爬进这个洞穴状的空间才能看到里面。那里躺着一个年轻女孩的尸体。是詹妮弗·巴斯蒂安。她仰面躺着，双腿分开，双臂伸向两侧。她的泳衣和短裤被拉下到右脚踝周围。她仍然穿着袜子、鞋子和自行车手套。她衣衫不整的状态和尸体被摆放的方式暗示她遭到了性侵，但她的遗体腐烂程度太严重，无法确认她是否被强奸。一根由
a thin rope was found around her neck. Her state of decomposition prevented investigators from conclusively determining whether there were other injuries, but it appeared her throat may have been cut as well. She was missing a tooth, suggesting her killer might have inflicted blunt force trauma. Jennifer's cause of death was determined to be asphyxia secondary to strangulation. Her bicycle was discovered lying on its side in some brush further towards the cliffs. It had been covered with fern fronds that had since died and turned brown. Jennifer's blue bike saddlebag was still attached with her white and red striped bike helmet inside. Other contents included a water bottle, some clothing, a bike manual, and Jennifer's pink and black Velcro wallet with three dollars and some loose change inside.
细绳制成的结扎物被发现缠在她的脖子上。腐烂状态使调查人员无法确定是否有其他伤害，但看起来她的喉咙可能也被割开了。她少了一颗牙齿，这表明凶手可能对她造成了钝器创伤。詹妮弗的死因被确定为勒死导致的窒息。她的自行车被发现侧倒在靠近悬崖的灌木丛中。它被蕨类植物覆盖，那些植物已经枯萎变黄。詹妮弗的蓝色自行车鞍包仍然挂在上面，里面装着她那顶红白条纹的自行车头盔。其他物品包括一个水壶、一些衣服、一本自行车手册，以及詹妮弗的粉色和黑色魔术贴钱包，里面有三美元和一些零钱。
Detectives faced the difficult task of informing the Bastions that their daughter had been found. Patty Bastion was at home painting the living room's walls when there was a knock on the front door. She would later tell Dateline journalist Keith Morrison that she could not bear to think of what had happened to her daughter, stating, I have my fairy tale, I think, and I'll just live with it. She was riding her bike, the monster came out of the woods and grabbed her and killed her. More than that, I can't wrap my brain around. Right away, the public began to speculate that Michelle Welch and Jennifer Bastion had been killed by the same man. Child abductions and murders were rare in Tacoma, and now there had been two under disturbingly similar circumstances within mere months of each other.
侦探们面临着通知巴斯蒂安一家女儿已被发现的艰巨任务。帕蒂·巴斯蒂安当时正在家里粉刷客厅的墙壁，这时前门响起了敲门声。她后来告诉《Dateline》记者基思·莫里森（Keith Morrison），她无法忍受去想女儿身上发生了什么，她说：“我想我有我的童话故事，我会一直活在里面。她当时在骑自行车，怪物从树林里出来抓住了她并杀死了她。除此之外，我的大脑无法理解。”公众立即开始猜测米歇尔·韦尔奇和詹妮弗·巴斯蒂安是被同一个人杀害的。儿童绑架和谋杀案在塔科马很少见，而现在在短短几个月内就发生了两起情况极其相似的案件。
Fear spread that there was a serial killer stalking Tacoma's parks and preying on girls. When asked whether this was the case, law enforcement officers were cagey, merely stating that at this point in time, they had no physical evidence linking the two cases. But behind closed doors, it was a different story. Almost immediately, investigators drew the conclusion that the two girls were victims of the same perpetrator. In addition to the similarities of their age, appearance and the circumstances of their disappearances, their bodies had been found posed in almost the same way, on their backs with their legs apart and arms outstretched. Both were exposed, with articles of clothing left in disarray around their ankles. Their remains had been hidden in wooded,
恐惧蔓延开来，人们担心有一个连环杀手在塔科马的公园里徘徊，并以女孩为猎物。当被问及是否如此时，执法人员含糊其辞，仅表示目前他们没有任何物理证据将这两起案件联系起来。但在幕后，情况却截然不同。调查人员几乎立即得出结论，这两个女孩是同一个肇事者的受害者。除了她们的年龄、外貌和失踪情况相似外，她们的尸体被发现时摆放的方式几乎相同，都是仰面躺着，双腿分开，双臂伸向两侧。两人都处于赤裸状态，衣物杂乱地留在脚踝周围。她们的遗体都被隐藏在茂密的、
isolated areas. Jennifer had a rope ligature around her neck, while a cord was found, though not used, at Michelle's scene. Michelle had definitely had her neck cut, and it was possible Jennifer had as well. Initially, it was wondered whether the two murders could have been committed by an as-yet unidentified serial killer who'd been dubbed the Green River Killer. The Green River Killer had been operating around the Tacoma and Seattle areas since four years earlier in 1982. By 1984, he had already killed five women and girls, and a special task force was formed
偏僻的区域。詹妮弗的脖子上有一根绳子结扎物，而在米歇尔的现场也发现了一根绳子，尽管没有使用。米歇尔的脖子确实被割开了，詹妮弗的可能也是。起初，人们怀疑这两起谋杀案是否可能是由一个尚未查明的连环杀手所为，该杀手被称为“绿河杀手”（Green River Killer）。绿河杀手自四年前的1982年以来一直在塔科马和西雅图地区作案。到1984年，他已经杀害了五名妇女和女孩，并成立了一个特别工作组
to handle the case. Investigators consulted renowned FBI profiler John Douglas and even spoke with convicted serial killer Ted Bundy in an attempt to build a picture of their suspect. Following Michelle and Jennifer's murders, the Green River Killer Task Force took a look at their cases, but they were deemed to have been committed by somebody else. A new task force was formed to coordinate the Welch and Bastion cases. Thousands of tips poured in from the public, and detectives interviewed hundreds of persons of interest, collecting their hair, blood, and saliva as well. One man soon came under scrutiny as their prime
来处理此案。调查人员咨询了著名的FBI侧写师约翰·道格拉斯（John Douglas），甚至与被定罪的连环杀手泰德·邦迪（Ted Bundy）交谈，试图勾勒出嫌疑人的形象。米歇尔和詹妮弗遇害后，绿河杀手特别工作组查看了她们的案件，但认为这些案件是其他人所为。一个新的特别工作组成立，以协调韦尔奇案和巴斯蒂安案。成千上万的线索从公众那里涌入，侦探们采访了数百名相关人员，并收集了他们的头发、血液和唾液。一名男子很快受到审查，成为他们的主要
suspect. Multiple people had reported him as a creeper who was known to sunbathe nude at Point Defiance Park. He drove a van and possessed strange drawings of young girls. Hair and blood samples subsequently ruled him out. Despite the abundance of calls from the public, none of the tips resulted in an arrest. Numerous suspects were identified, interviewed, and deemed plausible before later being cleared. If a suspect seemed likely for one of the cases but had an alibi for the other, he was ruled out. Several times a prime suspect came into focus, only to ultimately be eliminated for one reason or another. Months continued to pass and as soon the first anniversary of Michelle Welch's murder arrived, closely followed by that of Jennifer Bastian. By this time the task force had been disbanded, but two detectives still regularly checked in on the case
嫌疑人。多人报告说他是一个变态，以在点偏见公园裸体日光浴而闻名。他开着一辆货车，拥有奇怪的年轻女孩画作。头发和血液样本随后排除了他的嫌疑。尽管公众打来了大量电话，但没有一条线索导致逮捕。许多嫌疑人被确认、审讯，并在后来被排除之前被认为是合理的。如果一个嫌疑人看起来很可能是其中一起案件的凶手，但有另一起案件的不在场证明，他就会被排除。几次主要嫌疑人进入视野，但最终因某种原因被排除。几个月过去了，米歇尔·韦尔奇遇害一周年纪念日很快到来，紧随其后的是詹妮弗·巴斯蒂安的周年纪念日。到那时，特别工作组已经解散，但仍有两名侦探定期跟进此案，
and evidence from the crime scenes was still being processed. When speaking to the media, law enforcement spokespeople were adamant that the investigation was still very much active and ongoing. In 1989, three years after the murders, investigators sent the semen sample from Michelle's murder to a private laboratory in California for testing. DNA profiling was still in its infancy when it came to use in criminal investigations, with the first conviction based on DNA evidence having taken place in 1987. The California lab sent back the killer's profile, though there was no database for
犯罪现场的证据仍在处理中。在接受媒体采访时，执法部门发言人坚称调查仍然非常活跃且正在进行中。1989年，即谋杀案发生三年后，调查人员将米歇尔谋杀案中的精液样本送往加利福尼亚的一家私人实验室进行检测。DNA分析在刑事调查中的应用尚处于起步阶段，首例基于DNA证据的定罪发生在1987年。加州的实验室发回了凶手的档案，但没有数据库供
investigators to compare it to. Instead, they used it to rule out any potential suspects that emerged. By the mid-naughties, a more sophisticated DNA profile of the killer was created. By this time, there were state and federal databases that detectives could check the profile against. Yet, they couldn't find a match. Whoever the killer was, he seemingly didn't have a serious criminal history. Investigators wondered if the killer had been in the military and was now living far away elsewhere, or perhaps he'd died before he could commit any more murders. Without any arrests in their daughter's cases, the victims' families did their best to continue
调查人员进行比对。相反，他们用它来排除出现的任何潜在嫌疑人。到了2000年代中期，创建了更复杂的凶手DNA档案。到那时，已经有了侦探可以用来比对档案的州和联邦数据库。然而，他们找不到匹配项。无论凶手是谁，他似乎都没有严重的犯罪记录。调查人员怀疑凶手是否曾在军队服役，现在住在很远的地方，或者也许他在犯下更多谋杀案之前就已经死了。由于女儿的案件没有逮捕任何人，受害者的家属尽其所能继续
living. Michelle's mother Barbara took solace in her Christian faith and staunch belief that she would one day be reunited with her daughter. Jennifer's mother Patti likewise found comfort in religion and began coordinating a child safety fair that was held in Tacoma every year. In an interview with the News Tribune, she stated, I can always calm myself down with the knowledge that whether we as human beings solve the crime or not, it is solved. And whether justice happens in the criminal courts or the heavenly courts, it doesn't matter. It will happen. It will happen.
生活。米歇尔的母亲芭芭拉从她的基督教信仰中找到了慰藉，并坚定地相信有一天她会与女儿团聚。詹妮弗的母亲帕蒂同样从宗教中找到了安慰，并开始协调每年在塔科马举办的儿童安全博览会。在接受《新闻论坛报》（News Tribune）采访时，她说：“我总是可以用这样一个事实来让自己平静下来：无论我们作为人类是否破获了这起犯罪，它都已经解决了。无论正义是在刑事法庭还是在天堂法庭实现，这都不重要。它会实现的。它会实现的。”
In the summer of 1986, 11-year-old Lindsay Wade had her innocence shattered by the murders of Michelle Welch and Jennifer Bastian. Prior to learning about the two crimes, she'd been a carefree child growing up in Tacoma oblivious to the dangers that might exist. After she found out what had happened to Michelle and Jennifer, Lindsay became scared, like much of the broader community. The two girls were close to her in age and had been killed while out riding their bikes in local parks, something Lindsay also loved to do. All over Tacoma, everyone was asking how such a thing could have happened and who was responsible. Alarmist headlines and news stories added to Lindsay's fear and she no longer felt safe playing in the woods as she had before. This newfound fear persisted over the following years. As a junior high student, Lindsay
1986年夏天，11岁的琳赛·韦德（Lindsay Wade）因米歇尔·韦尔奇（Michelle Welch）和詹妮弗·巴斯蒂安（Jennifer Bastian）的谋杀案而失去了童年的纯真。在得知这两起罪案之前，她一直是个无忧无虑的孩子，在塔科马（Tacoma）长大，对可能存在的危险一无所知。在得知米歇尔和詹妮弗的遭遇后，琳赛和社区里的许多人一样感到恐惧。这两名女孩与她年龄相仿，都是在当地公园骑自行车时遇害的，而骑车也是琳赛最喜欢的活动。整个塔科马都在议论这种事怎么会发生，以及谁该负责。危言耸听的头条新闻和报道加剧了琳赛的恐惧，她再也无法像以前那样在树林里玩耍，感到安全了。这种新产生的恐惧在随后的几年里一直挥之不去。作为一名初中生，琳赛
sometimes had to walk past a wooded gulch on her way to school, and doing so always made her heart race. She couldn't help imagining a dangerous predator lurking nearby, waiting to snatch her. Looking back as an adult, it would later seem to Lindsay as though her entire childhood and adolescence was coloured by the two unsolved murders that devastated Tacoma in 1986. During high school, Lindsay developed an interest in criminal investigations after reading author Ian Rule's book about serial killer Ted Bundy, who was also from Tacoma. After graduating, Lindsay ultimately decided that she wanted to become a police officer and then a detective. She achieved both ambitions by 2003 when she was promoted to the role of detective at the Tacoma Police Department.
有时在上学路上必须经过一条树木繁茂的沟壑，这总是让她心跳加速。她不禁想象着附近潜伏着危险的掠食者，正等着抓她。成年后回首往事，琳赛觉得自己的整个童年和青春期似乎都被1986年摧毁塔科马的那两起未破谋杀案蒙上了阴影。高中期间，在读了作家伊恩·鲁尔（Ian Rule）关于同样来自塔科马的连环杀手泰德·邦迪（Ted Bundy）的书后，琳赛对刑事调查产生了兴趣。毕业后，琳赛最终决定成为一名警察，然后成为一名侦探。到2003年，她被提升为塔科马警察局的侦探，实现了这两个抱负。
The now detective Lindsay Wade spent time investigating auto thefts and was then assigned to the sex crimes department. In 2008, she was transferred to the homicide squad. In 2009, Detective Wade had her first child and took five months off for maternity leave. That same year, Tacoma Police Department established a cold case unit, which would be dedicated to investigating old, unsolved cases. They had more than 250 unsolved homicides and missing persons cases on their books, but the inspiration for the unit's formation was the 1986 murders of Michelle Welch and Jennifer Bastian. 23 years had passed since the two young girls were murdered, and both cases still remained
现任侦探琳赛·韦德曾花时间调查汽车盗窃案，随后被分配到性犯罪部门。2008年，她被调到凶杀组。2009年，韦德侦探有了第一个孩子，并休了五个月的产假。同年，塔科马警察局成立了一个悬案组，专门负责调查陈年未破案件。他们的记录中有超过250起未破的凶杀案和失踪人口案，但该部门成立的灵感来自于1986年米歇尔·韦尔奇和詹妮弗·巴斯蒂安的谋杀案。距离这两名年轻女孩遇害已经过去了23年，两起案件仍然
unsolved due in part to the police department not having the resources to dedicate to older cases. With a dedicated unit, detectives could finally take a closer look at the case files. When Detective Lindsay Wade returned from maternity leave, she began reviewing a number of the cold cases alongside the head of the unit, Detective Jean Miller. One of the cases Detective Wade began pouring over was that of Jennifer Bastion and Michelle Welch. The crimes that had haunted her since she was a little girl were even more disturbing up close and with access to all of the details. Over the next few years, Detective Wade returned to the case whenever she had the time. Motivated by the memory of the fear she had felt as a child and the desire to help get justice
悬而未决，部分原因是警察局没有资源投入到旧案件中。有了专门的部门，侦探们终于可以更仔细地查看案卷了。琳赛·韦德侦探产假归来后，开始与部门负责人吉恩·米勒（Jean Miller）侦探一起审查一些悬案。韦德侦探开始仔细研究的案件之一就是詹妮弗·巴斯蒂安和米歇尔·韦尔奇案。这些自她小时候起就困扰着她的罪行，在近距离接触并查阅所有细节后，显得更加令人不安。在接下来的几年里，韦德侦探只要有时间就会回到这个案子上。出于对童年恐惧记忆的驱使，以及想要帮助女孩们伸张正义的愿望，
for the girls, she painstakingly combed through the case file. In 2013, Detective Waite met Jennifer Bastien's parents for the first time during a visit to their home with Detective Miller. As the two investigators were leaving, Jennifer's father Ralph begged them to solve the case, adding that he didn't have much time left. He had been 59 when his daughter was murdered, and was now 86 years old. He desperately wanted to see justice for Jennifer before he died. Seeking additional expert opinions, the detectives took the case to the National Centre for Missing and Exploited Children in Virginia.
她一丝不苟地梳理了案卷。2013年，韦德侦探与米勒侦探一起拜访詹妮弗·巴斯蒂安的父母时，第一次见到了他们。当两位调查人员离开时，詹妮弗的父亲拉尔夫（Ralph）恳求他们破案，并补充说他剩下的时间不多了。女儿遇害时他59岁，现在已经86岁了。他迫切希望在去世前看到詹妮弗沉冤得雪。为了寻求更多的专家意见，侦探们将此案提交给了位于弗吉尼亚州的国家失踪与受虐儿童中心。
There, they spoke about the case with a panel of 20 experts, including current and former FBI agents, consultants specialising in crimes against children, and two forensic scientists. This trip helped galvanise the two detectives, and they came up with some new ideas as to where they could take the investigation. Subsequently, Detective Miller submitted Jennifer Bastion's swimsuit away for testing. The swimsuit had been worn by Jennifer on the day of her murder and was found around her ankle at the crime scene. Over the ensuing two and a half decades, it was preserved in evidence. DNA testing had advanced in leaps and bounds since then, and the detectives hoped that forensic
在那里，他们与一个由20名专家组成的专家组讨论了此案，其中包括现任和前任联邦调查局（FBI）特工、专门研究儿童犯罪的顾问以及两名法医科学家。这次行程极大地激励了两位侦探，他们对调查的方向产生了一些新的想法。随后，米勒侦探提交了詹妮弗·巴斯蒂安的泳衣进行检测。这件泳衣是詹妮弗遇害当天穿的，在犯罪现场被发现缠在她的脚踝上。在随后的二十五年里，它一直作为证据被保存着。自那时起，DNA检测技术突飞猛进，侦探们希望法医
scientists might be able to obtain a DNA profile for Jennifer from the swimsuit. This profile would then be used as a reference sample. In November 2013, the detectives received a phone call from a scientist at the laboratory. He asked whether they were also interested in a profile for the male DNA found in Jennifer's swimsuit. He explained that recovered in the crotch of the swimsuit was a semen sample, which had been tested and was found to belong to one man. The detectives were shocked. This evidence had been completely missed by the case's original investigators. Perhaps because the swimsuit had been removed from Jennifer's body, they had assumed the perpetrator's DNA
科学家或许能从泳衣中提取出詹妮弗的DNA图谱。该图谱随后将用作参考样本。2013年11月，侦探们接到了实验室一位科学家的电话。他询问他们是否也对在詹妮弗泳衣上发现的男性DNA图谱感兴趣。他解释说，在泳衣的裆部提取到了精液样本，经检测属于一名男子。侦探们大为震惊。这一证据完全被该案最初的调查人员忽略了。也许是因为泳衣是从詹妮弗身上脱下来的，他们认为凶手的DNA
wouldn't be on it. There was another shock to follow. Since the early 1990s, investigators had had a DNA profile for the killer of Michelle Welch and Jennifer Bastion. This had been built from semen recovered from Michelle Welch's remains. When the new sample from Jennifer's swimsuit was compared to that taken from Michelle's crime scene, investigators were stunned to find that it wasn't a match. They weren't looking for one killer. They were looking for two. They weren't looking for one killer. They were looking for two. This revelation totally upended the investigation. Almost from the start, detectives had believed the cases must have been connected.
不会留在上面。接下来还有另一个震惊的消息。自20世纪90年代初以来，调查人员就已经掌握了米歇尔·韦尔奇和詹妮弗·巴斯蒂安凶手的DNA图谱。这是从米歇尔·韦尔奇遗体中提取的精液中建立起来的。当将詹妮弗泳衣上的新样本与米歇尔犯罪现场提取的样本进行比对时，调查人员震惊地发现两者并不匹配。他们寻找的不是一个凶手。他们寻找的是两个。他们寻找的不是一个凶手。他们寻找的是两个。这一发现彻底颠覆了调查。几乎从一开始，侦探们就认为这两起案件一定有关联。
Stranger abductions, assaults and murders were rare, and Tacoma was seen as a safe upper-middle class city. The similarities between the two crimes were overwhelming, right down to the victim profiles, the manner of the attacks, and the locations they had taken place in. What were the odds that the two girls had been killed by two different men within just four months of each other. Yet, now the DNA made clear that two separate individuals bore responsibility. Perhaps Jennifer's murder had been a copycat crime with Michelle's providing the inspiration, but that was as far as the connection went.
陌生人绑架、袭击和谋杀案很少见，塔科马被视为一个安全的中上层阶级城市。两起罪案之间的相似之处令人震惊，甚至连受害者特征、袭击方式和发生地点都如出一辙。两个女孩在短短四个月内被两个不同的男人杀害的几率有多大？然而，现在DNA清楚地表明，两个独立的个体负有责任。也许詹妮弗的谋杀案是一起模仿犯罪，米歇尔的案件提供了灵感，但联系仅限于此。
connection, but that was as far as the connection went. Over the past decade, investigators had run the DNA from Michelle's case through the Combined DNA Index System, or CODIS, the United States National Police DNA database. They'd never found a match. Now they checked the profile from Jennifer's killer. It wasn't a match to anyone in the CODA system either. That meant neither killer had a criminal record. Detectives had also used the DNA from Michelle's case to eliminate more than 100 possible suspects from both cases. Now, it was possible that those individuals could still be suspects in Jennifer's murder. Similarly, other persons of interest had been ruled out because they'd been incarcerated or had alibis for one of the murders.
联系，但联系仅限于此。在过去十年中，调查人员已将米歇尔案中的DNA通过联合DNA索引系统（CODIS），即美国国家警察DNA数据库进行了比对。他们从未找到匹配项。现在他们检查了詹妮弗凶手的图谱。它与CODIS系统中的任何人都不匹配。这意味着两个凶手都没有犯罪记录。侦探们还利用米歇尔案中的DNA排除了两起案件中100多名可能的嫌疑人。现在，这些人仍有可能是詹妮弗谋杀案的嫌疑人。同样，其他相关人员也因为在其中一起谋杀案发生时被监禁或有不在场证明而被排除。
The fact investigators were now looking for two killers would mean those individuals would need to be looked at again. Detective Jean Miller began compiling a list of suspects who hadn't been eliminated via DNA. The goal was now to obtain voluntary samples from them so they could be checked against the evidence. Roughly two dozen individuals willingly provided their DNA to detectives and were gradually ruled out as suspects. Detective Lindsay Wade trawled through the police department's old records, searching for any cases with similarities to Jennifer Bastion's. Any time she came across the name of a suspect or person of interest, she would look them up and run a background check. When they couldn't be eliminated through DNA
调查人员现在寻找两名凶手的事实意味着需要重新审视这些人。吉恩·米勒侦探开始编制一份未通过DNA排除的嫌疑人名单。现在的目标是获得他们的自愿样本，以便与证据进行比对。大约有二十几个人自愿向侦探提供了他们的DNA，并逐渐被排除在嫌疑人之外。琳赛·韦德侦探翻阅了警察局的旧记录，寻找任何与詹妮弗·巴斯蒂安案有相似之处的案件。每当她看到嫌疑人或相关人员的名字，她就会查找并进行背景调查。当他们无法通过DNA排除时，
in CODIS, she would often add them to the list for voluntary sample collection. This work was slow. In January of 2015, Detective Miller retired, and Detective Wade replaced him as the lead investigator. Months later, Detective Wade utilised the innovative technique of phenotyping to gain a clearer picture of her suspects. Phenotyping involves identifying a person's physical characteristics based on the DNA. The results indicated that Jennifer's murderer was white with light eyes and blonde or red hair. Michelle's killer was predominantly of European heritage but had 9% Native American ancestry. He had fair skin, a round face,
在CODIS中，她通常会将他们加入自愿采集样本的名单中。这项工作进展缓慢。2015年1月，米勒侦探退休，韦德侦探接替他成为首席调查员。几个月后，韦德侦探利用创新的表型分析技术来更清晰地了解她的嫌疑人。表型分析包括根据DNA识别一个人的身体特征。结果显示，詹妮弗的凶手是白人，浅色眼睛，金发或红发。米歇尔的凶手主要是欧洲血统，但有9%的美洲原住民血统。他皮肤白皙，圆脸，
brown or hazel eyes, and brown hair. Composite sketches of both men were created and shared with the public. That same year, Detective Wade learned of a cutting-edge technique that might help in the case. Investigators were now using Y chromosome DNA to hone in on potential suspects. As Y chromosome DNA is passed down from father to son, men who share the same YSTR DNA profile typically have the same surname. The exceptions are when a son has been given his mother's last name, is adopted, or is unaware of his true biological father's identity. Some genealogists involved in forensic investigations were now using YSTR DNA profiles to come up with possible surnames for male suspects.
棕色或淡褐色眼睛，棕色头发。两名男子的合成素描被制作出来并向公众发布。同年，韦德侦探了解到一种可能有助于破案的前沿技术。调查人员现在正在使用Y染色体DNA来锁定潜在嫌疑人。由于Y染色体DNA是从父亲传给儿子的，拥有相同Y-STR DNA图谱的男性通常拥有相同的姓氏。例外情况是儿子随母姓、被收养或不知道自己真实的亲生父亲身份。一些参与法医调查的系谱学家现在正在使用Y-STR DNA图谱来推断男性嫌疑人可能的姓氏。
Detective Wade wasn't sure about this new technique but figured it was worth a shot. She reached out to Dr Colleen Fitzpatrick, a genealogist who had founded a forensic genealogy organisation called Identifiers International. The detectives sent the profile of Jennifer's killer to Dr. Fitzpatrick asking for any possible surnames that might be associated with it. Three names were sent back, Smith, Holbrook, and Washburn. Wondering if anyone with those names might be mentioned in the case file, Detective Wade scoured it for the name Holbrook, but found nothing. Given how Common Smith was as a surname, the detective didn't think she'd have any luck there. She turned her attention to the final name on the list, Washburn.
韦德侦探对这项新技术不太确定，但觉得值得一试。她联系了系谱学家科琳·菲茨帕特里克（Colleen Fitzpatrick）博士，她创立了一个名为“标识符国际”（Identifiers International）的法医系谱组织。侦探们将詹妮弗凶手的图谱发送给菲茨帕特里克博士，询问可能与之相关的任何姓氏。三个名字被发回：史密斯（Smith）、霍尔布鲁克（Holbrook）和沃什伯恩（Washburn）。想知道案卷中是否提到了这些名字的人，韦德侦探搜寻了“霍尔布鲁克”这个名字，但一无所获。考虑到“史密斯”这个姓氏有多普遍，侦探认为她在那儿不会有什么运气。她将注意力转向名单上的最后一个名字：沃什伯恩。
One result came back. In May 1986, several months before Jennifer was murdered, a man named Robert Washburn called the police with a tip-off for the Michelle Welch case. He said that he'd seen the suspect sketch of Michelle's killer and realised that he'd recognised it. Washburn said he'd been out jogging when he saw a man who resembled the sketch loitering in a park. But he hadn't seen the man in Puget Park, where Michelle was killed. He said the man had been at Point Defiance Park, the location where Jennifer would be attacked and killed three months later. In December of that year, detectives had paid Robert Washburn a visit at home to follow up on his tip-off. He'd repeated his story about seeing a man who resembled the sketch in Point Defiance Park, lurking near the Rhododendron Garden.
有一个结果。1986年5月，在詹妮弗遇害前几个月，一名叫罗伯特·沃什伯恩（Robert Washburn）的男子打电话给警察，为米歇尔·韦尔奇案提供了一条线索。他说他看到了米歇尔凶手的嫌疑人素描，意识到他认出了那个人。沃什伯恩说他在慢跑时看到一个长得像素描里的人在公园里徘徊。但他没有在米歇尔遇害的普吉特公园（Puget Park）看到那个人。他说那个人是在点偏转公园（Point Defiance Park），也就是三个月后詹妮弗遇袭并遇害的地方。那年12月，侦探们曾到罗伯特·沃什伯恩家中拜访，以跟进他的线索。他重复了他的故事，说在点偏转公园看到一个长得像素描里的人，潜伏在杜鹃花园附近。
Washburn explained that he jogged in the park up to twice a day, always along the trails off Five Mile Drive. He had lost his job, so had plenty of time to do so. He'd added that he'd been in the park after Jennifer Bastion went missing and saw police searching. He'd also noticed a foul smell emanating from Five Mile Drive in the subsequent weeks but hadn't known what it was. The 1986 detectives had found nothing suspicious in Robert Washburn's conduct or demeanour. They noted his name in the case file and left it at that. file, and left it at that. Detective Lindsay Wade was somewhat dubious about the YSTR surname selection, but she added Robert Washburn to her list of persons of interest to be approached for a voluntary
沃什伯恩解释说，他每天在公园慢跑多达两次，总是沿着五英里大道（Five Mile Drive）的小径。他失业了，所以有充足的时间这样做。他补充说，詹妮弗·巴斯蒂安失踪后他也在公园里，看到警察在搜寻。在随后的几周里，他还注意到五英里大道散发出一种恶臭，但不知道那是什么。1986年的侦探们在罗伯特·沃什伯恩的行为或举止中没有发现任何可疑之处。他们在案卷中记下了他的名字，仅此而已。琳赛·韦德侦探对Y-STR姓氏筛选有些怀疑，但她还是将罗伯特·沃什伯恩列入了她的相关人员名单，准备联系他进行自愿
DNA sample. She'd been painstakingly creating a record of every mail mentioned in Jennifer's case file along with whether or not their DNA was on file. There were more than 2,300 names on the list. It was ordered from most to least suspicious, and individuals were only eliminated from the list if their DNA failed to match or if they'd been incarcerated at the time of the murder. Detective Wade was assisted by a special agent from the FBI and together they were able to track down and obtain DNA samples from a number of suspects. After a few months, Detective Wade's department had chased down 121 suspect samples from Washington to be tested.
DNA样本采集。她一直在费力地建立一份记录，记录詹妮弗案卷中提到的每一位男性，以及他们的DNA是否在案。名单上有超过2300个名字。名单按可疑程度从高到低排列，只有当他们的DNA不匹配或在谋杀发生时被监禁时，个人才会被从名单中排除。韦德侦探在一名联邦调查局特工的协助下，成功追踪并获得了多名嫌疑人的DNA样本。几个月后，韦德侦探的部门已经追查了来自华盛顿州的121份嫌疑人样本进行检测。
The FBI focused on interstate persons of interest, tracking down an additional 40 samples. Testing all of these took a long time. During 2017, Detective Wade submitted more than 100 to be tested. None were a match. A second batch was also submitted with no positive results. In January 2018, Detective Wade sent a final batch of 18 samples away for testing. Given so many promising suspects had already been ruled out after having their DNA tested, her hopes were low. Several months later in April, Detective Wade retired from the Tacoma Police Department. She'd been there for 14 years and the job had left her
联邦调查局专注于州际相关人员，又追踪到了40份样本。检测所有这些样本花费了很长时间。2017年期间，韦德侦探提交了100多份样本进行检测。没有一个是匹配的。第二批样本也被提交，没有阳性结果。2018年1月，韦德侦探寄出了最后一批18份样本进行检测。鉴于许多有希望的嫌疑人在DNA检测后已被排除，她不抱太大希望。几个月后的4月，韦德侦探从塔科马警察局退休。她在那里工作了14年，这份工作让她
burnt out. Less than one month after her last day, Lindsay Wade was at home when she received a phone call from the detective who had taken over her role. After she answered, he immediately asked if she was sitting down, then stated, stated, "'There's a match on Jennifer Bastion.' In shock and unable to speak, it took Lindsay a minute before she asked for the man's name. Robert Washburn," the detective replied. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads.
精疲力竭。在她最后一天上班不到一个月后，琳赛·韦德在家中接到了接替她职位的侦探打来的电话。接听后，对方立即问她是否坐着，然后说：“詹妮弗·巴斯蒂安案有匹配结果了。”琳赛震惊得说不出话来，过了一分钟才问那个人的名字。“罗伯特·沃什伯恩，”侦探回答。案卷稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本集的广告。
By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. In 1986, Robert Washburn was 28 years old. He lived about two miles from Point Defiance Park and was divorced. He and his wife had split the year before after six years of marriage. and his wife had split the year before after six years of marriage. 1985 hadn't been great for Washburn overall as he was also arrested that year on suspicion of vehicle prowling and criminal trespass. However, he ultimately wasn't charged and consequently had no criminal record. The next time he'd come to police attention was in May 1986 when he'd reported seeing the suspect in the Michelle Welch case hanging around at Point Defiance Park. Given the timing of this call and the fact it took place before Jennifer Bastion's murder, investigators would later wonder if Washburn was already scheming to kill a girl and frame
通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供高质量的内容。1986年，罗伯特·沃什伯恩28岁。他住在离点偏转公园约两英里的地方，已经离婚。他和妻子在结婚六年后的前一年分开了。1985年对沃什伯恩来说总体上并不好，因为他那年还因涉嫌车辆盗窃和非法侵入而被捕。然而，他最终没有被起诉，因此没有犯罪记录。他下一次引起警方注意是在1986年5月，当时他报告说在点偏转公园看到米歇尔·韦尔奇案的嫌疑人徘徊。考虑到这通电话的时间，以及它发生在詹妮弗·巴斯蒂安谋杀案之前，调查人员后来会怀疑沃什伯恩是否已经在策划杀害一个女孩并嫁祸给
the other murderer for it. Another theory was that he'd become fixated by the Michelle Welch case and got a thrill out of inserting himself into the investigation. Maybe his fixation had grown to the point where he'd decided to commit a copycat crime. In the years that followed, Washburn began working for an airplane and aerospace company as a mechanic. He remarried in 1990 and he and his second wife had a daughter. During the late 1990s, they relocated to the Washington city of Burlington. Robert Washburn filed for bankruptcy in 2000 and about a decade later he relocated to the state of Illinois. He was found there by the FBI in March 2017 after Detective Lindsay Wade added his name to her suspect list. By then Washburn was 60 years old and living in the city of Eureka with
另一个凶手。另一种理论是，他被米歇尔·韦尔奇案迷住了，并从介入调查中获得了快感。也许他的痴迷已经发展到他决定实施模仿犯罪的地步。在随后的几年里，沃什伯恩开始为一家飞机和航空航天公司担任机械师。他于1990年再婚，他和第二任妻子有一个女儿。20世纪90年代末，他们搬到了华盛顿州的伯灵顿市（Burlington）。罗伯特·沃什伯恩于2000年申请破产，大约十年后，他搬到了伊利诺伊州。2017年3月，在琳赛·韦德侦探将他的名字加入嫌疑人名单后，联邦调查局在那里找到了他。那时沃什伯恩已经60岁了，住在尤里卡市（Eureka），和
his now 25 year old daughter. She had cerebral palsy and required a feeding tube and Washburn was her full-time caregiver. When the FBI asked Washburn for a DNA sample he obliged. It would take more than a year for the results to come back, yet Washburn made no attempt to relocate or flee during that time. When FBI agents returned to his home to arrest him in May 2018, he went willingly and didn't fight extradition to Washington. His cooperation only went so far though, as he refused to speak with detectives. When told that his DNA matched that of a murder suspect, he stated, I did not kill that little girl. Up until that point, detectives hadn't disclosed that the case was related to a young girl. Washburn explained the presence of his DNA as being due to his frequent visits to Point Defiance
他现在25岁的女儿住在一起。她患有脑瘫，需要喂食管，沃什伯恩是她的全职看护人。当联邦调查局要求沃什伯恩提供DNA样本时，他照办了。结果出来花了一年多的时间，但沃什伯恩在此期间没有试图搬迁或逃跑。当联邦调查局特工于2018年5月回到他家逮捕他时，他自愿配合，没有反抗引渡到华盛顿。不过，他的配合仅限于此，因为他拒绝与侦探交谈。当被告知他的DNA与一名谋杀案嫌疑人匹配时，他声称：“我没有杀那个小女孩。”在此之前，侦探们并没有透露该案与一个小女孩有关。沃什伯恩解释说他的DNA出现在那里是因为他经常去点偏转
Park, saying, "...my DNA was all over that park." Robert Washburn was returned to Tacoma and arraigned in court after being charged with the Jennifers murder. Many of those who knew him were shocked. Neighbours described him as a kind but quiet man who kept to himself and was devoted to his daughter. Disturbingly though, he was known to be very friendly with a 12-year-old girl who lived in his apartment building. The girl often visited Washburn at his home and he was seen giving her
公园，说：“……我的DNA遍布那个公园。”罗伯特·沃什伯恩被送回塔科马，在被控谋杀詹妮弗后在法庭上受审。许多认识他的人都感到震惊。邻居们形容他是一个善良但安静的人，独来独往，对女儿很孝顺。然而令人不安的是，据了解，他与住在他公寓楼里的一名12岁女孩非常友好。这个女孩经常去沃什伯恩家，有人看到他给她
chocolate and gifts. This girl was later interviewed and said Washburn had never abused her, but he had taken photos of her doing gymnastics. Robert Washburn's computer and technological devices were seized. Child sexual abuse material was recovered from these, and it was revealed that Washburn had also kept tabs on unsolved murders and missing persons cases in the state of Washington. Shortly after Washburn's arrest, an inmate who'd met Washburn on remand in the county jail contacted authorities to say that Washburn had confessed to the crime. Washburn said that on the day Jennifer Bastion went missing, he'd been jogging in Point Defiance Park and simultaneously looking for someone to have sex with. He said he did this often, describing himself as a quote, sick kinky fuck.
巧克力和礼物。这个女孩后来接受了采访，说沃什伯恩从未虐待过她，但他拍过她做体操的照片。罗伯特·沃什伯恩的电脑和电子设备被查封。从中恢复了儿童性虐待材料，并揭露了沃什伯恩还一直在关注华盛顿州的未破谋杀案和失踪人口案。沃什伯恩被捕后不久，一名在县监狱候审期间见过沃什伯恩的囚犯联系了当局，称沃什伯恩承认了罪行。沃什伯恩说，在詹妮弗·巴斯蒂安失踪的那天，他一直在点偏转公园慢跑，同时寻找可以发生性关系的人。他说他经常这样做，形容自己是一个“变态的混蛋”。
Washburn told the inmate that while hanging around Five Mile Drive, he'd found Jennifer's abandoned bike and hid it in the bushes. he'd found Jennifer's abandoned bike and hid it in the bushes. Later that night, he saw on the news that the bike had belonged to a missing girl named Jennifer Bastion. Washburn said that he'd subsequently gone back to where he'd hidden the bike and wiped it down. After doing so, he decided to look for Jennifer and discovered her deceased body nearby. Washburn told the other inmate that he'd stood over Jennifer's remains and masturbated. That was how his DNA had ended up on her swimsuit. Washburn had accurately described the way Jennifer was posed and her state of undress.
沃什伯恩告诉那名囚犯，在五英里大道附近徘徊时，他发现了詹妮弗被遗弃的自行车，并把它藏在灌木丛中。那天晚上晚些时候，他在新闻中看到那辆自行车属于一个名叫詹妮弗·巴斯蒂安的失踪女孩。沃什伯恩说，他随后回到藏自行车的地方，把它擦干净了。做完这些后，他决定寻找詹妮弗，并在附近发现了她已故的尸体。沃什伯恩告诉另一名囚犯，他站在詹妮弗的遗体上自慰。这就是他的DNA最终出现在她泳衣上的原因。沃什伯恩准确地描述了詹妮弗被摆放的姿势和她衣衫不整的状态。
accurately described the way Jennifer was posed and her state of undress. Subsequently, Washburn changed his story. He said he'd noticed Jennifer Bastion riding her bike and said he couldn't help himself as she was so, quote, exquisite. He had raped and strangled her. He didn't say whether this crime was spontaneous or premeditated, but investigators suspected the latter. The cave-like space where Jennifer's body was left had been prepared well in advance. Although he claimed he jogged daily at the park, those who knew him said Washburn never jogged at all, meaning he more likely went there looking for victims. Perhaps Washburn had seen Jennifer riding her bike around the park on other occasions and planned to attack her in the wake of Michelle Welch's murder. Or
准确地描述了詹妮弗被摆放的姿势和她衣衫不整的状态。随后，沃什伯恩改变了他的说法。他说他注意到詹妮弗·巴斯蒂安骑着自行车，说他无法控制自己，因为她太“精致”了。他强奸并勒死了她。他没有说这起罪行是突发性的还是预谋的，但调查人员怀疑是后者。詹妮弗尸体被留下的洞穴状空间是提前准备好的。尽管他声称每天在公园慢跑，但认识他的人说沃什伯恩根本不慢跑，这意味着他更有可能是去那里寻找受害者。也许沃什伯恩在其他场合看到詹妮弗在公园里骑自行车，并计划在米歇尔·韦尔奇谋杀案发生后袭击她。或者
maybe his choice of victim was opportunistic, but detectives had no doubt that Washburn had gone to Point Defiance Park on August 4, 1986 with the intention of raping and murdering a girl. According to the inmate, Washburn also admitted that he'd been keeping tabs on the Bastion family in the years after the murder. He said he didn't want his family to know what he'd been keeping tabs on the Bastion family in the years after the murder. He said he didn't want his family to know what he'd done, while claiming he also wanted to receive the death penalty. Despite this, Robert Washburn continued to maintain his innocence for another nine months while the prosecution began to put their case against him together. months while the prosecution began to put their case against him together. Then, he abruptly changed his mind and decided to enter a guilty plea. This news was a huge relief to the Bastion
也许他选择受害者是机会主义的，但侦探们毫不怀疑沃什伯恩于1986年8月4日带着强奸和谋杀女孩的意图去了点偏转公园。据那名囚犯称，沃什伯恩还承认，在谋杀案发生后的几年里，他一直在关注巴斯蒂安一家。他说他不想让家人知道他做了什么，同时声称他也想被判处死刑。尽管如此，罗伯特·沃什伯恩在接下来的九个月里继续坚称自己无罪，而检方开始整理针对他的案件。然后，他突然改变了主意，决定认罪。这个消息对巴斯蒂安
family who would be spared the pain of a trial. Tragically, Jennifer's father Ralph had passed away two and a half years prior to Washburn's arrest and hadn't lived to see her case solved. Jennifer's mother Patti and her big sister Theresa attended Robert Washburn's sentencing in January 2019. Both read victim impact statements to the court. Theresa said that she had been so devastated by Jennifer's murder that she'd never ridden a bike again or taught her own daughter how to do so due to the terrible association.
一家来说是一个巨大的解脱，他们将免受审判的痛苦。可悲的是，詹妮弗的父亲拉尔夫在沃什伯恩被捕前两年半就去世了，没能活着看到她的案件告破。詹妮弗的母亲帕蒂（Patti）和她的姐姐特蕾莎（Theresa）参加了2019年1月罗伯特·沃什伯恩的判决听证会。两人都向法庭宣读了受害者影响陈述。特蕾莎说，她被詹妮弗的谋杀案摧毁了，以至于她再也没有骑过自行车，也没有教自己的女儿骑车，因为这种可怕的联想。
Addressing Washburn directly, she stated, "...you made me an only child." Patty Bastion described the ongoing suffering their family had been left with, saying that even on beautiful summer days, there was always a cloud of fear and foreboding. Robert Washburn did not address the court, but a statement he had written earlier was read aloud. Despite the presence of his seamen at the crime scene and Jennifer's state of undress, he maintained that he hadn't sexually assaulted her. Instead, he claimed he had grabbed her by the arm, led her into the woods and strangled her. He said he was admitting to this to spare the Bastions and his own family the trauma of a trial,
在直接对沃什伯恩说话时，她说：“……你让我成了独生女。”帕蒂·巴斯蒂安描述了他们一家所遭受的持续痛苦，说即使在美丽的夏日，也总有一层恐惧和不祥的阴云。罗伯特·沃什伯恩没有向法庭陈述，但宣读了他早些时候写的一份声明。尽管犯罪现场有他的精液且詹妮弗衣衫不整，但他坚称自己没有性侵她。相反，他声称他抓住她的手臂，把她带进树林并勒死了她。他说他承认这一点是为了让巴斯蒂安一家和他自己的家人免受审判的创伤，
adding that he was sorry for what he'd done and how many people he'd hurt. He looked it down as the judge sentenced him to 27 years in prison. Now aged 61, this made it unlikely that he would ever experience freedom again. this made it unlikely that he would ever experience freedom again. Outside court, Patty Bastion told the media there had been a sense of relief in the courtroom that day. Referencing the way Washburn had stared down the entire time, refusing to meet her eyes, she stated, I guess that's the picture of a guilty man." After Robert Washburn's arrest, media reports celebrated the long-awaited resolution in the decades-old cold case. They simultaneously noted that the murder of Michelle Welch,
并补充说，他对自己的所作所为以及伤害了多少人感到抱歉。当法官判处他27年监禁时，他低下了头。现年61岁的他，这使得他几乎不可能再重获自由。法庭外，帕蒂·巴斯蒂安告诉媒体，那天法庭上有一种解脱感。提到沃什伯恩一直盯着看、拒绝与她对视的方式，她说：“我想这就是一个有罪之人的写照。”罗伯特·沃什伯恩被捕后，媒体报道庆祝了这起几十年前的悬案终于得到解决。他们同时指出，米歇尔·韦尔奇的谋杀案，
long thought to be related to Jennifer's case, remained unsolved. Yet, behind the scenes, it was a different story. Lindsay Wade and other detectives had been re-investigating Michelle's case in parallel to Jennifer's, applying the same breakthroughs in DNA. In 2017, Detective Wade sent the suspect's DNA from Michelle's body to genealogy consultant Dr Barbara Rae Venter. Genetic genealogy was starting to be used as a way to solve cold cases, with the genealogists examining online family trees to identify unknown suspects whose DNA hadn't been uploaded to police databases. Using the websites Family Tree DNA and GEDmatch, Dr Ray Venter was able to identify two individuals who were the suspect's second cousins or first cousins once removed. She requested the assistance of DNA technology company Parabon Nano Labs in studying the
长期以来被认为与詹妮弗的案件有关，仍然未破。然而，在幕后，情况却截然不同。琳赛·韦德和其他侦探一直在与詹妮弗案并行重新调查米歇尔的案件，应用了同样的DNA突破。2017年，韦德侦探将从米歇尔遗体上提取的嫌疑人DNA发送给系谱顾问芭芭拉·雷·文特（Barbara Rae-Venter）博士。遗传系谱学开始被用作解决悬案的一种方式，系谱学家检查在线家谱，以识别DNA未上传到警察数据库的未知嫌疑人。利用Family Tree DNA和GEDmatch网站，雷·文特博士能够识别出两名嫌疑人的表亲或远房表亲。她请求DNA技术公司Parabon Nano Labs协助研究
genealogy. The company's genetic genealogy unit had made a name for itself by solving a number of cold cases. Headed by renowned genealogist C.C. Moore, the unit employed four genealogists in total who examined online family trees to identify unknown suspects. The DNA from Michelle's case was sent to Parabon Nano Labs in May 2018. The Parabon team quickly calculated that the suspect was mostly white with 9% Native American heritage. They also identified the same two cousins as Dr Ray Venter. The cousins were not directly related to each other, meaning they were related to the
系谱。该公司的遗传系谱部门通过解决多起悬案而声名鹊起。该部门由著名系谱学家C.C.摩尔（CeCe Moore）领导，总共雇用了四名系谱学家，他们检查在线家谱以识别未知嫌疑人。米歇尔案中的DNA于2018年5月被送往Parabon Nano Labs。Parabon团队很快计算出嫌疑人主要是白人，有9%的美洲原住民血统。他们还确定了与雷·文特博士相同的两名表亲。这些表亲之间没有直接关系，这意味着他们与
unknown suspect on different branches of the same family tree. When Cece Moore examined the built-out family trees of the suspects' two cousins, she noticed that one of them, known as Clyde S, had two first cousins who looked interesting. They were brothers with ties to Tacoma, who both shared the surname Hartman. Their names were Gary and Darjeh. On their paternal side, Gary and Darjeh Hartman had two second great-grandmothers who were Native American. This was consistent with the amount of Native American ancestry found in the suspect's DNA. Furthermore, in 1986, Gary and RJ had both lived in the Tacoma area, residing in the North End neighbourhood. This was less than a mile from where Michelle was attacked in Puget Park. RJ had been in his late 20s and Gary in his mid-30s when Michelle was killed, making them both old
未知嫌疑人在同一家谱的不同分支上有亲缘关系。当C.C.摩尔检查嫌疑人两名表亲建立的家谱时，她注意到其中一个被称为“克莱德·S”（Clyde S）的人有两个看起来很有趣的表亲。他们是兄弟，与塔科马有联系，都姓哈特曼（Hartman）。他们的名字是加里（Gary）和达杰（Darjeh）。在父系方面，加里和达杰·哈特曼有两位曾曾祖母是美洲原住民。这与在嫌疑人DNA中发现的美洲原住民血统数量一致。此外，1986年，加里和达杰都住在塔科马地区，居住在北端社区。这距离米歇尔在普吉特公园遇袭的地方不到一英里。米歇尔遇害时，达杰已接近30岁，加里已30多岁，这使他们两人都足够
enough to be the killer. Neither of the Hartman brothers were named in the Michelle Welch-Shaw Jennifer Bastian case files. They had never come under any suspicions for the murders at all. But based on the recommendation of C.C. Moore at Parabon Nano Labs, detectives decided that they needed to obtain DNA samples from both Gary and RJ to compare to the suspect's profile. They would do so surreptitiously, given they had no way of getting a voluntary sample without alerting the brothers to their suspect status. RJ seemed the more likely suspect. His wife had alleged that he was abusive when she had filed for a divorce in 1993 and obtained a restraining order against him. The couple had later reconciled, but this still seemed like a red flag. In contrast, RJ's older brother Gary was
大，可能是凶手。哈特曼兄弟俩都没有在米歇尔·韦尔奇和詹妮弗·巴斯蒂安的案卷中被提及。他们从未对这些谋杀案产生任何怀疑。但根据Parabon Nano Labs的C.C.摩尔的建议，侦探们决定需要从加里和达杰那里获取DNA样本，以与嫌疑人的图谱进行比对。他们将秘密进行，因为他们无法在不提醒兄弟俩他们是嫌疑人的情况下获得自愿样本。达杰看起来更像是嫌疑人。他的妻子在1993年申请离婚并获得针对他的限制令时，曾指控他有虐待行为。这对夫妇后来和解了，但这似乎仍然是一个危险信号。相比之下，达杰的哥哥加里是
a family man with no allegations against him and a long career as a nurse at a mental health facility. On Saturday June 2, 2018, a detective from Tacoma Police Department tailed RJ as he visited a state park. When RJ threw away a Coke can, the detective pounced and took it into evidence. A week later, detectives again followed RJ as he dined at a restaurant with his family. He drank three cocktails, sipping each of the drinks through a straw. When staff at the restaurant cleared the table, detectives approached them and collected the straws, as well as a glass RJ had drunk water from. DNA profiles were constructed from these items. RJ Hartman wasn't a match. R.J. Hartman wasn't a match.
一个顾家的人，没有针对他的指控，并且在一家精神卫生机构担任护士，职业生涯很长。2018年6月2日星期六，塔科马警察局的一名侦探跟踪达杰，当时他正在参观一个州立公园。当达杰扔掉一个可乐罐时，侦探猛扑过去并将其作为证据带走。一周后，侦探们再次跟踪达杰，当时他正与家人在一家餐馆用餐。他喝了三杯鸡尾酒，每杯都用吸管啜饮。当餐馆的工作人员清理桌子时，侦探们走近他们并收集了吸管，以及达杰喝过水的杯子。从这些物品中构建了DNA图谱。达杰·哈特曼不匹配。达杰·哈特曼不匹配。
In 1986, Gary Hartman was 35 years old and lived a short distance from Puget Park. In fact, he'd lived on the same street as Robert Washburn, though their homes were about 10 blocks apart. Now, more than three decades later, Hartman was 66 and still resided in Washington, about 10 miles southwest of Tacoma in the city of Lakewood. On Tuesday, June 5, 2018, detectives surveilled Hartman's home and followed him as he drove in his turquoise Chevy pickup to Western State Hospital, the psychiatric facility where he was employed. Hartman went inside the hospital before soon returning to the parking lot with a female colleague. The pair got into a work vehicle and made their way to a nearby McDonald's restaurant. Once again, the detectives followed. McDonald's restaurant. Once again, the detectives followed. Hartman and his colleague went inside the McDonald's and sat down at a table after ordering some breakfast. Two detectives did
1986年，加里·哈特曼35岁，住在离普吉特公园不远的地方。事实上，他住在和罗伯特·沃什伯恩同一条街上，尽管他们的家相距约10个街区。现在，三十多年过去了，哈特曼66岁，仍然住在华盛顿州，在塔科马西南约10英里的莱克伍德市（Lakewood）。2018年6月5日星期二，侦探们监视了哈特曼的家，并跟踪他驾驶他的绿松石色雪佛兰皮卡车前往西部州立医院（Western State Hospital），这是他工作的精神病院。哈特曼走进医院，不久后与一名女同事回到停车场。两人坐进一辆工作车，前往附近的一家麦当劳餐厅。侦探们再次跟踪。麦当劳餐厅。侦探们再次跟踪。哈特曼和他的同事走进麦当劳，点了一些早餐后坐在桌旁。两名侦探
the same, choosing a table about 10 feet from Hartman. They watched as Hartman drank his coffee, which he'd poured into a mug he'd brought with him. As Hartman ate his breakfast, he used a brown paper napkin to wipe his mouth several times. When he was done, he crumpled up the napkin and tossed it into the McDonald's bag his food had been served in, along with his receipt and empty wrappers. Hartman then crumpled up the bag and set it to one side, while continuing to chat with his colleague and sip his coffee. One of the detectives approached a McDonald's employee who was cleaning the area and explained who he was. He asked if she would collect Hartman's bag from him under the guise of doing her job,
做了同样的事情，选择了一张距离哈特曼约10英尺的桌子。他们看着哈特曼喝咖啡，他把咖啡倒进了自己带来的杯子里。当哈特曼吃早餐时，他用一张棕色纸巾擦了几次嘴。吃完后，他把纸巾揉成一团，扔进了装食物的麦当劳袋子里，连同他的收据和空包装纸。然后哈特曼把袋子揉成一团，放在一边，继续与同事聊天并啜饮咖啡。其中一名侦探走近一名正在清理该区域的麦当劳员工，并解释了自己的身份。他询问她是否可以假装履行职责，从哈特曼那里拿走他的垃圾，
so they could take it into evidence. The employee agreed and went up to Hartman asking if she could remove his rubbish for him. He agreed, waving at the bag to indicate she should take it. The employee collected it and it was subtly handed over to the detectives. The napkin was processed for a DNA analysis. The profile obtained from it was a perfect match to the DNA recovered from 12-year-old Michelle Walsh's body. Two weeks later, at 5.30am on Wednesday June 20, police officers arrived at Hartman's home and waited quietly for him to leave. He emerged five hours later at 10.30 and drove away in an SUV.
以便他们可以将其作为证据带走。员工同意了，走到哈特曼面前，询问是否可以帮他清理垃圾。他同意了，挥手示意袋子，表示她应该拿走。员工收走了袋子，并悄悄交给了侦探。纸巾被送去进行DNA分析。从中获得的图谱与从12岁米歇尔·韦尔奇遗体上提取的DNA完美匹配。两周后，6月20日星期三凌晨5点30分，警察到达哈特曼家，静静地等待他离开。他五小时后在10点30分出现，开着一辆SUV离开。
He was followed by his adult daughter in another car. Officers pursued the father and daughter and when Hartman braked at a stop sign, they pulled in alongside and in front of him. A detective approached Hartman's window, which Hartman rolled down. You're under arrest. Turn off the car and step out, the detective said. Hartman did as he was told, asking why he was being arrested as he was handcuffed. He was informed that he would be told the reason later. Hartman was subsequently charged with the rape and murder of Michelle Welch. Officers accompanied Hartman's daughter
他的成年女儿开着另一辆车跟着他。警察追赶这对父女，当哈特曼在停车标志处刹车时，他们停在他旁边和前面。一名侦探走近哈特曼的车窗，哈特曼摇下了车窗。“你被捕了。熄火下车，”侦探说。哈特曼照做了，在被戴上手铐时询问为什么要逮捕他。他被告知稍后会告诉他原因。哈特曼随后被控强奸和谋杀米歇尔·韦尔奇。警察陪同哈特曼的女儿
home and executed a search of the property. This was no easy task as the house was in poor condition. Detectives would describe it as a near-hoarder house with cardboard boxes full of various items stacked from floor to ceiling in multiple rooms. Heavy layers of dust covered the furniture. There were dog feces on the kitchen floor and a neglected pet dog found outside. Officers were looking for any evidence relating to Michelle's murder. They recovered multiple folding knives, two handguns and lots of ammunition. They had been hoping to find Michelle's pink eyeglasses which weren't found with her body. Unfortunately, the glasses were never recovered. Gary Hartman denied killing Michelle Welch and said he wanted to speak with an attorney
回家并对房产进行了搜查。这不是一项容易的任务，因为房子状况很差。侦探们将其描述为近乎囤积者的房子，多个房间里堆满了从地板到天花板装满各种物品的纸板箱。厚厚的灰尘覆盖着家具。厨房地板上有狗粪，外面发现了一只被忽视的宠物狗。警察正在寻找与米歇尔谋杀案有关的任何证据。他们发现了多把折叠刀、两把手枪和大量弹药。他们一直希望找到米歇尔的粉红色眼镜，但没有在她的遗体旁找到。不幸的是，眼镜从未被找回。加里·哈特曼否认杀害了米歇尔·韦尔奇，并表示他想与律师交谈。
when he was told what he was being charged with. Bucal swabs taken by detectives confirmed that he was a match to the killer. Prior to becoming a mental health technician in 1992, Gary Hartman had been in the Navy and then had a series of menial jobs. He seemed to find his niche in mental health care, later getting a job as a registered nurse in 1998. He had been married four different times to three different women. He was divorced twice and married to his second wife at the time of Michelle's murder. Hartman's marriages with his first two wives broke down due to his infidelity. He wed his third wife in 1996 and they were still together at the time of his arrest. The couple had two adopted daughters. Hartman's family said he was a functioning alcoholic, but his attorney claimed
当他被告知自己被指控的罪名时。侦探提取的口腔拭子证实他与凶手相符。在1992年成为心理健康技术员之前，加里·哈特曼曾在海军服役，随后从事了一系列卑微的工作。他似乎在心理健康护理领域找到了自己的位置，后来在1998年获得了一份注册护士的工作。他曾与三位不同的女性有过四次婚姻。他离过两次婚，在米歇尔遇害时，他正与第二任妻子维持婚姻关系。哈特曼与前两任妻子的婚姻因他的不忠而破裂。他在1996年与第三任妻子结婚，在被捕时他们仍在一起。这对夫妇有两个领养的女儿。哈特曼的家人说他是一个功能性酗酒者，但他的律师声称
he had found sobriety in 1989 at the age of 38. R.J. Hartman told police his older brother had been abusive when R.J. was a child, hitting him with a baseball bat, choking him to the point of unconsciousness and tying RJ up in the garage when Hartman was supposed to be babysitting. RJ also accused his brother of raping him and said he'd tortured and killed animals. According to RJ, Hartman loathed women, a result of his hatred for his mother. She suffered from alcoholism and was an abusive parent. RJ claimed that when his mother had female friends over and they passed out from drinking, Hartman would rape them. RJ said that Hartman had long been fascinated by little girls. He'd made inappropriate remarks about RJ's daughter when
他在1989年38岁时已经戒酒。R.J.哈特曼告诉警方，当R.J.还是个孩子时，他的哥哥曾虐待他，用棒球棍打他，掐他直到失去知觉，并在哈特曼本该照看他时把他绑在车库里。R.J.还指控他哥哥强奸了他，并说他曾折磨并杀害动物。据R.J.说，哈特曼厌恶女性，这是他仇恨母亲的结果。他的母亲患有酗酒症，是一位虐待成性的家长。R.J.声称，当他母亲邀请女性朋友来家里喝酒喝醉后，哈特曼会强奸她们。R.J.说，哈特曼长期以来一直对小女孩着迷。当R.J.的女儿
she was eight years old. It would turn out that one year after Michelle's murder, Gary Hartman was arrested for public indecency after he exposed himself to a young girl at a store. He was arrested for this crime but for some reason was never convicted and had no criminal record. However, he was ordered to see a psychiatrist. In a disturbing twist of fate, it would turn out that RJ's daughter had been school friends with Jennifer Bastion. Gary Hartman had been fascinated by Jennifer's case and frequently spoke of it to his family. He claimed he was friends with a detective working on the case and so he knew things about it that others didn't. He never spoke of Michelle Walsh's murder. But RJ had often
八岁时，他曾对她发表过不当言论。事实证明，在米歇尔遇害一年后，加里·哈特曼因在商店向一名小女孩暴露自己而被捕。他因这项罪名被捕，但出于某种原因从未被定罪，也没有犯罪记录。然而，他被要求去看精神科医生。命运的转折令人不安，事实证明，R.J.的女儿曾是詹妮弗·巴斯蒂安的同学。加里·哈特曼一直对詹妮弗的案件很着迷，并经常向家人提起。他声称自己与负责此案的一名侦探是朋友，因此他知道一些别人不知道的事情。他从未提起过米歇尔·沃尔什的谋杀案。但R.J.经常
considered reporting his brother as a suspect for the murders of the two girls. The crimes seemed like something he was capable of. RJ couldn't remember exactly when, but around the time of Michelle's murder, Hartman had shown up panicking on his front door in the middle of the night. He asked RJ to tell anyone who asked that he'd been there all night, claiming he'd been cheating on his wife and didn't want to get caught. Gary Hartman refused to plead guilty, but his attorney did strike another kind of deal with the prosecution. Hartman would waive his right to a jury trial and have a bench trial instead. This meant the verdict would be decided by a judge, assuring a guilty conviction while still allowing Hartman to plead not guilty.
考虑举报他的哥哥是这两起谋杀案的嫌疑人。这些罪行看起来像是他能做出来的事。R.J.记不清具体时间，但在米歇尔遇害前后，哈特曼曾在半夜惊慌失措地出现在他家门口。他要求R.J.告诉任何询问的人他整晚都在那里，声称他背着妻子出轨，不想被抓到。加里·哈特曼拒绝认罪，但他的律师确实与检方达成了另一种协议。哈特曼将放弃陪审团审判的权利，转而进行法官审判。这意味着判决将由法官决定，既能确保定罪，又能让哈特曼保持不认罪的立场。
As a consequence of this deal, the prosecution and defence negotiated a sentence of 26 years and 6 months and agreed to certain stipulated facts surrounding Michelle's murder. One of these facts was that Hartman's semen had been found on Michelle's body, though the first degree rape charge against him was dropped. Hartman did not provide any details as to why or how he had approached and attacked Michelle. In May 2022, Gary Hartman was found guilty of the first degree murder of Michelle Wulch. Although Hartman's sentence had already been agreed upon, his attorney argued there were mitigating factors that should be taken into consideration,
作为这项协议的结果，检方和辩方协商了26年零6个月的刑期，并就米歇尔谋杀案周围的某些既定事实达成了一致。其中一个事实是，在米歇尔的尸体上发现了哈特曼的精液，尽管针对他的一级强奸指控被撤销了。哈特曼没有提供任何关于他为何或如何接近并袭击米歇尔的细节。2022年5月，加里·哈特曼被判谋杀米歇尔·沃尔什的一级谋杀罪成立。尽管哈特曼的刑期已经商定，但他的律师辩称，有一些减轻处罚的因素应该被考虑在内，
such as the childhood abuse Hartman had been subjected to by both his parents. The judge dismissed this, stating that nothing Hartman had experienced prior to 1986 could excuse or minimise his brutal murder of a child. He was sentenced to the agreed upon 26 years and six months in prison. Now aged in his late 60s, Gary Hartman will most likely die during his incarceration. Hartman will most likely die during his incarceration. Hartman sobbed loudly and repeatedly apologised as Michelle Welch's loved ones shared their victim impact statements. One of Michelle's aunts told the court that the murder hadn't just impacted their family, it had traumatised an entire community. Adding, 30 years is a long time to agonise over who did this
例如哈特曼在童年时期遭受的父母双方的虐待。法官驳回了这一说法，称哈特曼在1986年之前经历的任何事情都不能为他残忍杀害一名儿童的行为开脱或减轻罪责。他被判处商定的26年零6个月监禁。现年60多岁的加里·哈特曼很可能会在服刑期间死亡。哈特曼很可能会在服刑期间死亡。当米歇尔·沃尔什的亲人分享他们的受害者影响陈述时，哈特曼大声啜泣并反复道歉。米歇尔的一位阿姨告诉法庭，这起谋杀案不仅影响了他们的家庭，还给整个社区带来了创伤。并补充说，30年是一个很长的时间，让人痛苦地思考是谁做了这件事
to Michelle and why is he still living a free life? Michelle's sister, Nicole, spoke of how the crime had ended her childhood, given her repeated nightmares and impacted her other relationships. repeated nightmares and impacted her other relationships. She stated, "'Forgiveness is the only way to keep me from being infected by the continual pain and keep furthering it on. I do not wish any harm to come to him because I would be of the same spirit as him. Though our lives are linked together because of this tragedy, I do not want to be of the same mindset in harming others. Michelle's mother Barbara spoke of how she had often wished she could trade places with Michelle. Quote, Michelle was a happy child. She was also trusting. Too trusting. a happy child. She was also trusting. Too trusting. This is the day Hartman faces the judge.
对米歇尔做了这些，为什么他还能过着自由的生活？米歇尔的姐姐妮可讲述了这起罪行是如何终结了她的童年，给她带来了反复的噩梦，并影响了她的人际关系。反复的噩梦并影响了她的人际关系。她说：“宽恕是让我不被持续的痛苦所感染并继续传播它的唯一途径。我不希望他受到任何伤害，因为那样我就和他一样了。虽然我们的生命因为这场悲剧而联系在一起，但我不想在伤害他人方面有同样的心态。”米歇尔的母亲芭芭拉讲述了她曾多次希望自己能与米歇尔交换位置。引用：“米歇尔是一个快乐的孩子。她也很信任别人。太容易信任别人了。太容易信任别人了。这是哈特曼面对法官的日子。
I say lock him up and throw away the key. It won't bring her back, but justice will have been served. In 2023, former detective Lindsay Wade published a memoir titled In My DNA about her life and her time in the Tacoma Police Department, focusing heavily on the impact Michelle and Jennifer's murders had on her life. As Gary Hartman's case was still before the courts at the time of publication, Lindsay couldn't go into detail about Michelle's investigation. However, she did write in detail about her work on Jennifer Bastion's case and how it was finally solved. Over the years, Lindsay had formed a strong bond with the Jennifer's mother Paddy, and the two were close. Although Robert Washburn's arrest came after Lindsay had retired as a detective,
我说把他关起来，扔掉钥匙。这不会让她回来，但正义将得到伸张。2023年，前侦探琳赛·韦德出版了一本名为《在我的DNA中》的回忆录，讲述了她的生活和在塔科马警察局工作的时光，重点关注了米歇尔和詹妮弗的谋杀案对她生活的影响。由于加里·哈特曼的案件在出版时仍在法庭审理中，琳赛无法详细介绍米歇尔的调查情况。然而，她确实详细写了她在詹妮弗·巴斯蒂安案件中的工作以及它是如何最终被解决的。多年来，琳赛与詹妮弗的母亲帕迪建立了深厚的联系，两人关系密切。尽管罗伯特·沃什伯恩的逮捕发生在琳赛退休之后，
she was still permitted to be the one to break the news to the Bastion family. In her book, Lindsay describes how she knocked on Paddy's front door and informed her, we got him. The two women hugged and cried as the news they had waited so long for began to sink in. One month after Jennifer's mother finally received answers, Michelle's mother Barbara got the news she had been waiting three decades for as well. She would later say that upon learning her daughter's killer had been apprehended, she got shivers up her spine. In 2019, Washington passed a new law inspired by the cases of the two girls.
她仍然被允许成为向巴斯蒂安一家传达消息的人。在书中，琳赛描述了她如何敲开帕迪的前门并告诉她：“我们抓到他了。”当她们等待了这么久的消息终于尘埃落定时，两位女性拥抱并哭泣。在詹妮弗的母亲终于得到答案一个月后，米歇尔的母亲芭芭拉也得到了她等待了三十年的消息。她后来表示，在得知女儿的凶手被捕后，她感到脊背发凉。2019年，华盛顿州通过了一项受这两名女孩案件启发的新法律。
Jennifer and Michelle's law has expanded the state's DNA databases by requiring those convicted of indecent exposure to provide a DNA sample to CODIS. The legislation also allows detectives to obtain DNA samples from deceased sex offenders. Patty Bastion worked on the law alongside Lindsay Wade and told reporters that, Knowing the good it's going to do is just amazing. When 18 year old Nea May went missing in 2002, her family did everything they could to help the police find her. But, like so many missing persons cases, there comes a time when the leads dry up and there's nowhere left to look.
《詹妮弗和米歇尔法案》扩大了该州的DNA数据库，要求那些因猥亵暴露罪被定罪的人向CODIS提供DNA样本。该立法还允许侦探从已故的性犯罪者那里获取DNA样本。帕蒂·巴斯蒂安与琳赛·韦德一起致力于这项法律，并告诉记者：“知道它将带来的好处真是太棒了。”当18岁的妮娅·梅在2002年失踪时，她的家人尽其所能帮助警方寻找她。但是，像许多失踪人口案件一样，总会有一个线索枯竭、无处可寻的时候。
At no point have we just got on with our lives. I heard something recently that really resonated. It was a woman from America who said that you never get over grief, you learn to move forward with it. And I was like, that's the best anyone's ever described it. Niamh's sister, Fionnuala, realised that a podcast might help find the answers the family was looking for. So for the past four years, I've working with Nehems family to take a
我们从未有过一刻放下生活继续前进。我最近听到了一些真正引起共鸣的话。那是一位来自美国的女性，她说你永远无法克服悲伤，你学会了带着它继续前进。我当时想，这是任何人描述得最好的方式。妮娅的姐姐菲奥努拉意识到，播客可能有助于找到家人正在寻找的答案。因此，在过去的四年里，我一直与妮娅的家人合作，以
closer look at the case and what we found took us to places we never anticipated. Here's everything we've done. We've obviously got serious concerns about her welfare. I've just spoken to the last person to see her alive that we knew about and he's given me a bullshit story. When I first started looking into this case in 2020, it was originally intended to be a single case file episode. But the more I looked, the more I found. So Steve, he's adamant that she never made it to Gokup Road. Stan is adamant that there's a credible sighting there. Nehems set out for a gap year after finishing high school to test her independence,
更深入地审视这个案件，我们发现的事情带我们去了我们从未预料到的地方。这是我们所做的一切。我们显然对她的安危有严重的担忧。我刚刚和我们所知的最后一个见到她活着的人谈过，他给了我一个胡扯的故事。当我最初在2020年开始调查这个案件时，它原本打算成为一个单集案件档案。但我看得越多，发现的就越多。所以史蒂夫，他坚信她从未到达过Gokup路。斯坦坚信那里有一个可信的目击记录。妮娅在高中毕业后开始了一年的间隔年，以测试她的独立性，
but she never made it home. What happened in those final days? And when the black hearse arrived, these two men got out and as soon as I saw them and I saw that black hearse I thought their baddies stay away from them. Mum called me and she said, look, the police are investigating now and somebody claims that they dropped her off and she was hitchhiking. What started out as a potential case file episode turned into a 12-part series that took over four years to research. He didn't smile or anything, he just kind of looked empty and just like get in the car. It was just kind of like aggressively like get in the car. Join me as we uncover what happened in Missing Neham, the new 12-part podcast series from Casefile Presents. Something had obviously woken me
但她再也没有回家。在最后几天发生了什么？当那辆黑色灵车到达时，这两个人下来了，我一看到他们，看到那辆黑色灵车，我就想，他们是坏人，离他们远点。妈妈给我打电话说，看，警察现在正在调查，有人声称他们把她放下了，她当时在搭便车。原本可能是一个案件档案的剧集变成了一个历时四年多研究的12集系列。他没有笑什么的，他只是看起来很空洞，就像‘上车’。这就像是一种侵略性的‘上车’。加入我，让我们揭开《失踪的妮娅》中发生了什么，这是来自Casefile Presents的全新12集播客系列。显然有什么东西把我吵醒了
suddenly because I was disorientated. That's when I realised that there was just a cold rough hand holding my hand because I had my hand over the edge of the bed and I could see the outline of somebody leaning over the bed. Eva I guess has to be somewhat attractive doesn't it otherwise I wouldn't be able to sneak into every corner. So I whispered to my sister, asked her if she was awake and she said yes. I said there's someone in the room and she said I know. Missing Nehiem is available now. Be sure to download and follow Missing Nehiem wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
突然，因为我感到迷失方向。就在那时，我意识到有一只冰冷粗糙的手握着我的手，因为我的手放在床边，我可以看到有人弯腰在床上的轮廓。伊娃，我想这一定得有点吸引力，否则我就没法溜进每个角落了。所以我对我姐姐耳语，问她是否醒着，她说是的。我说房间里有人，她说我知道。《失踪的妮娅》现已上线。请务必在您获取播客的任何地方下载并关注《失踪的妮娅》。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。